there are plenty of big secrets at the
SCP Foundation but sometimes you've just
got to wonder what are the smaller
Secrets here at SC SCP explained we
often zoom out to give you a bird's eyee
view of the bizarre and sometimes
inexplicable events concerning a huge
number of anomalies but today we're
ditching our telescope in favor of a
microscope to take a look into the daily
life of one very special Blobby boy SCP
999 the Tickle Monster we took the Li of
painstakingly stalking um I mean
observing scp-999 going about his daily
life bringing joy to everyone around him
and not only were our otherwise cold
dead Hearts thoroughly warmed we were
also able to compile everything we
needed to make this video you're
watching right now welcome one and all
to a day in the life of SCP 999 6:30
a.m. rise and shine happy campers we
discover that the Tickle Monster likes
to start his day day nice and early
after all the more Daylight you have out
there the easier it is to put the
sunshine in people's hearts so shortly
after waking up SCP 999 uses his little
Blobby pseudo pods to put on some
pleasant easy listening music in his
containment chamber delightful he then
drinks a glass of delicious soy milk and
helps himself to a balanced breakfast of
chocolate M&M's and a variety of tasty
fruit flavored gummies please note this
is not an acceptable balance breakfast
for human beings it's important to
remember that scp-999 has very different
dietary needs to us humans believe me I
tried the SCP 999 diet all I got was
severe sugar headaches and overtime on
the toilet but the less said about that
the better after eating his delicious
sugary breakfast the Tickle Monster
grabs a crayon and starts building his
day plan which is normally filled with a
wide array of stimulating activities
every day is a new journey into
excitement for SC C
p999 this is part of SCP 999 schedule
that we very much recommend you emulate
setting your goals nice and early may
help you solidify your goals nice and
early and also help you feel a warm and
fuzzy sense of accomplishment when the
day ends and all your errands are
complete but by the time all this is
done for SCP 999 it's already 800 a.m.
of course while setting goals for the
day ahead is an important task
scp-999 in its surprisingly applicable
wisdom also knows the power of
inspiration that's why at around 8:00
a.m. the Tickle Monster indulges in his
morning entertainment before any tasks
or cross tests begin this largely
involves watching cartoons on a
television set provided to him by his
handlers at the SCP Foundation SCP 99's
favorite shows include SpongeBob
SquarePants Blues Clues and The
Backyardigans the foundation is
extremely careful with the programming
that SCP 999 is allowed to indulge in
making Ure that all the shows are
generally wholesome and sweet with
positive moral messages that one can
carry forward into their day SpongeBob
is a particular favorite for that exact
reason the Tickle Monster sees that
Plucky yellow sponge as a kind of
kindred spirit reminding him to keep a
positive can do attitude and a sense of
childlike fun after a few episodes of
the show 999 is typically bouncing with
joy and more than feeling SpongeBob's
iconic catchphrase I'm ready and while
it isn't necessarily relevant we'd also
like to state that within the confines
of this metaphor Dr gears is Squidward
moving on 10:00 a.m. now the Tickle
Monster is really ready to take on the
day having filled up on the two
essential Seas of any prosperous day
candy and cartoons he's ready to Slither
out there and make a difference his
first order of business for the workday
is sitting in on the daily site9 senior
researcher meeting where the top brass
of the site is given a collective
debrief on the day's task masks and
given an opportunity to share any Vital
Information of course morning meetings
can be stressful especially when you
work at the SCP Foundation where your
daily task might be SCP 682 seems
particularly canger today mind paying a
visit to his containment chamber and
asking him about it however SCP 999
being there in the room is kind of like
having the ultimate scented candle he
exudes those chill relaxing Vibes and
even the pleasant smell that puts you in
a place of profound ease
the foundation has discovered that since
SCP 999 has started sitting in on the
morning meetings both employee
satisfaction and task completion have
increased happy workers as it turns out
are also hard workers when the meetings
end and the senior researchers are
filing out of the room each one of them
gives SCP 999 a little hug or a Pat in
hopes of thanking him for all he does
this increases their emotional
well-being as well as SCP 999s it's one
of the rare everyone wins scenarios
you'll find at the SCP Foundation after
the meeting SCP 999 tends to roam around
the site for a while searching for
anyone in need as you probably already
know the Tickle Monster has an innate
sense for when people are in need of his
unique brand of anomalous positivity if
a researcher or a guard is feeling down
scp-999 will have an innate sense of
their presence and mercilessly hunt them
down to give them some pep they'll never
forget allow us to give you a specific
example security officer Dan Richardson
was stressed while he didn't let on to
anyone else working at the foundation
fearing that showing emotion would make
people think less of him his wife was
actually struggling from a severe
illness so when he went into work even
when he was guarding the containment
chambers of truly terrifying monsters
like
scp-106 he was only ever worrying about
her nobody else knew except for SCP 999
when the the Tickle Monster sense Dan's
distress he slithered over and began to
climb on him unleashing his rays of
anomalous Good Vibes soon enough Dan
felt a kind Freedom he hadn't
experienced since the beginning of his
wife's illness later that day he felt
the courage to visit the site 19
employee mental health counselor at last
and became open about his emotional
struggles it began a long but worthwhile
road to recovery all of which began with
SCP 999 and then the Tickle Monster
broke for lunch 12 p.m. at around midday
every day SCP 999 slithers on over to
the main site 19 cafeteria to enjoy a
wholesome lunch with Foundation
personnel and some of the other friendly
anomalies that do lunch with them he'll
grab a bowl of ice cream and a colorful
Jello-O pot from the friendly lunch lady
and Slither on over to the table where
SCP 073 cane and SCP 343 God are sitting
around chatting no hard feelings about
the whole loud Mark thing right God says
biting into his hamburger it is a
process Kan replies any awkwardness that
was there before immediately evaporated
when SCP 999 entered the scene both of
these mysterious anomalies smiled and
began petting him as he CED and trilled
God levitated the spoon to feed 999 his
ice cream which Cain thought was a
little show offy but held his tongue
because he was lost in the moment Kane
helped 999 peel off the lid to his
Jell-O pot with his precise mechanical
fingers Dr kleff Who was eating a few
tables over also dropped in to give SCP
999 a playful pat on the head and given
that Dr cleff typically has the
sensibility of an Xbox 360 Call of Duty
Lobby this show of vulnerability was an
exceptional act indeed Dr brigh would
have done the same but he was spending
lunch in 05 Council detention again
because he did something really stupid
again what was it this time see if you
can guess 1:30 p.m. after lunch SCP 999
would spend the next half an hour having
the nature of his father the terrifying
Scarlet King explained to him for those
privy to certain secret documents you'll
know that
scp-999 comes from the most unlikely of
parents the interdimensional universe
destroying monarch of chaos and evil
known as The Scarlet King he was
actually the progyny of the Scarlet
King's seventh bride whose son was
prophesized to one day defeat and
Dethrone the Scarlet King not through
violence and hatred but through a love
and kindness so great it burns out the
Crimson con's darkness of course he's
not ready to go toe-to-toe with his
estranged father just yet nor would the
foundation want him to they've made
mistakes in the past by being too gun ho
and prematurely weaponizing anomalies
under their care just look at the
absolute disaster that unfolded when
they tried to make Abel part of a mobile
task force and he killed all his
foundation comrades when they ran out of
missions to give him that's why they've
decided to take a very different
approach with SCP 99 99 rather than
pushing him too hard too early they've
decided to start drip feeding him the
knowledge piece by piece every day after
lunch some of the more scholarly
researchers have been reading him Choice
extracts from davite scriptures
concerning the Scarlet King they always
follow it up with a little rert the bear
though just so things don't get too
intense 2: p.m. after this unique SCP
Foundation take on story time is done
SCP 999 is once again free to Roman
around the site dispensing joy to
whoever needs it most something you need
to understand about
scp-999 is that he's utterly
non-judgmental even a beast of pure
violence and hatred like SCP 682 is
considered a potential friend to 999 you
may even remember the time that 999 was
able to live up to his name and tickle
the hardto destroy reptile into
submission inducing a hysterical
laughing fit in this otherwise hardcore
beasty that's why 999 would sometimes
stray into the dark spooky areas of the
site that most people would Fear To
Tread if they weren't specifically
assigned there for starters he nestled
up against the outside of SCP 049 the
plague doctor's cell the Sinister
surgeon was feeling a little down in the
dumps due to his continued failure to
Stamp Out the pestilence and the SCP
foundation's stubborn unwillingness to
help him in the task however a loving
visit from the Tickle Monster even on
the other side of a plexiglass divider
was enough to chase the blue away just
when he needed the encouragement most
this strengthened the doctor's resolve
he would continue his research no matter
how many lives it took to perfect his
Curative method admittedly not the best
result of an interaction with SCP 999
but 999 was at least happy that the
peculiar beaked man seemed a little less
depressed now at least even if the lack
of depression may lead to a few further
murders down the line who would be next
on SCP 99's Rampage of joyfulness and
Positive Vibes SCP 999 like the
benevolent is a friend to all children
so he does what he can to improve the
quality of life for anomalous children
contained by the SCP Foundation as part
of his daily rounds he makes sure to
always visit SCP 053 the young girl as
his positivity Aura is too powerful for
the girl's anomalous ability to
passively cause paranoia and violence to
affect him she often reports having a
wonderful time during their sessions
though she wishes her big Dragon friend
could come join in on their tea parties
too 400 p.m. by this time SCP 999 is
back to roaming again searching out
people or anomalies he can lend a
helping hand to helping people if you
hadn't somehow realized it by now is one
of 99's greatest joy in life that's why
when slithering near the high security
humanoid containment wing and seeing
groups of researchers running for the
hills he got the sense that perhaps he
was needed here and decided to
investigate further as all the
researchers ran screaming in One
Direction scp-999 slithered audaciously
in the other he heard one of the
researchers yelling the old man got out
sound the alarm and run for your lives
of course this did nothing to deter SCP
999 even as the Containment Breach
Sirens blasted through the air around
him 999 didn't fear death he only feared
failure failure in the task to make
everyone around him as happy as possible
up to and including some of the most
horrific and depraved Monsters the SCP
Foundation has ever contained very much
including the Monstrous creature coming
towards him down the hall the old man
SCP 106 gave a throaty chuckle as he
shuffled down the tiles his black goo
fizzling on the ground with one hand he
traced his fingertips along the wall
spreading corruption that ate away at
the wall like a cancer with the other
hand he dragged a rapidly melting corpse
that had once been a hapless researcher
standing too close to the wall of 106's
containment chamber now the old man was
eager to cause more pain and havoc in
the rest of the facility before he was
forced back into containment until he
ran into SCP 999 coming towards him in
the hallway suddenly 106 felt something
change in his mind his typically sharp
predatory sadistic thoughts suddenly
felt odd and fuzzy almost formless it
was almost like he'd been hit by some
kind of anomalous chloroform that dulled
the edge of his evil and then he was
laughing why because this strange Blobby
creature had crawled up onto his body
and begun to tickle him relentlessly it
didn't make sense how come this creature
wasn't affected by his corrosive mucus
but it was already too late he was
doubled over onto the floor cackling and
unlucky for the old man but luckily for
everyone else it was enough to pacify
him until a mobile task force with
high-intensity lights showed up and
shephered him back into containment it
was a truly humiliating defeat for SCP
106 but at the same time he'd be chish
to deny that he had somewhat of a good
time 700 p.m. as we get deeper into the
evening SCP 999 still has plenty to do
after all every day that ends at the SCP
Foundation also Heralds the end of many
people's lives and that's on a good day
too needless to say there would always
be plenty of people who needed cheering
up at the end of each day and nobody was
more up to the task than the Tickle
Monster first scp-999 decided to make
its way down to the site 19 medical Bay
to treat everyone who'd experien varying
degrees of horrific injury from a
typical day's work at the foundation
some were horrifically burned others
were missing parts some were pretty much
catatonic with the mental trauma of the
things they'd seen many had distinctive
fresh wounds that could only come from
SCP 682s massive Claws and fangs it was
a powerful Wellspring of misery SC SCP
9999 slithered from bed to bed nuzzling
up to the different patients of the
medical Bay and lifting their moods
you'd be amazed at the medicinal
benefits of a positive mindset and he's
one of the few Medical Treatments that
won't utterly destroy you if you don't
have insurance after helping the injured
SCP 999 decided to visit the d-class
barracks While most of the SCP
Foundation looked down on the lowly D
classes especially given the criminal
history of many of them SCP 999 held no
much prejudices he sensed that the
people in the barracks were confused and
scared for their safety and that was
enough for him to get in there and help
he slithered through the gang way
observing that some of the bunk beds
were empty from the day's less stressful
tests these Harden criminals many of
which were literal murderers immediately
felt themselves softening in the
presence of this cheerful Blobby
creature for the first time in many of
their long difficult and tragic lives
they dared to believe that perhaps
everything might be okay sometime in the
Noto distant future and SCP 999 couldn't
be happier about that 9:30 p.m. as the
night winds down one of the researchers
assigned to SCP 999 reads him a bedtime
story to help him wind down after an
exciting day SCP 999 tries not to go to
bed too late at night knowing that in
early bedtime and an early rise ensure
health and energy whale song and white
noise is played over a small radio while
SCP 9999 settles down to sleep ready to
have only the sweetest dreams so ends
another wonderful day and there you have
it folks a day in the life of the
endlessly adorable SCP 999 is there
anything from the tickle monsters daily
routine that you think you might start
incorporating into your own day-to-day
lives let us know down in the comments
personally in a world that can sometimes
be cold and cruel we think having the
strength to be a little Kinder and smile
a little brighter can make a far bigger
difference to some people than you'll
ever understand and nobody exemplifies
that better than SCP
999 while some higher level researchers
specialized guards and containment
experts at the SCP Foundation have fixed
an nomess projects tailored to their
very particular set of skills for many
lower level operatives including Junior
researchers guards janitorial staff and
even the dreaded DCL classes every day
is showing up spinning the wheel of
Misfortune and finding out how you might
die today will you be hacked to Pieces
by a murder monster pulled into a portal
turned into a doll eaten alive made into
a living Nest by bugs stretched out and
broken drowned exanguination set on fire
beaten to death by a volley of anomalous
tomatoes because you decided to drop a
cringeworthy dad joke or a rancid pun
there are perhaps only a handful of
anomalies that not only will not harm
you but will actively enrich your life
by getting to spend time with them and
of course Chief among these is the
legendary SCP 999 also known by its
adorable moniker the Tickle Monster we
don't need to get into too much detail
in describing this gelatinous ray of
sunshine his anomalous delightfulness
has made him somewhat of a celebrity
compared to the murderer's row of
terrifying entities and monsters around
him the researcher assigned to him today
was troubled having seen one of his
favorite co-workers devoured by SCP 682
the day before getting assigned to
feeding and checking on SCP 999 today
was exactly what he needed as he entered
the room several bags of M&M's in hand
the creature CED perhaps sensing his
tension and approached him immediately
the researcher felt a wave of calm and
contentment wash over him the incredible
and rare feeling that perhaps everything
is going to be all right for once 999
rubbed up against his leg as he poured
M&M's into its eager mouth radiating
Good Vibes the whole whole time what an
asset what a gift and to think this
adorable little goober was prophesized
to someday save the world that much
seemed almost funny but he was certainly
more than capable of saving the life of
someone who hadn't felt the warmth of
internal sunshine in quite some time and
for that much the researcher was
profoundly grateful he left 99's chamber
that day with a renewed sense of hope
for the future that maybe just maybe
they might be able to pull through to
make a difference to push this crazy
ball of rock we call our home in the
right direction maybe someday the Sun
would rise on a perfect world who would
have thought that a strange Sunrise
could change everything emergency Sirens
went off across the globe but in every
case they were drowned out by a terrible
endless chorus of Screams but below all
that you'll hear another gut-wrenching
sound a low but pervasive sizzling like
an egg on a hot pan
as billions of human beings started to
change their states of matter the SCP
Foundation had fought off and contained
so many seemingly impossible threats
from interdimensional Horrors like the
hanged sealed and Scarlet Kings to
nightmarish Mass Killers like SCP 106
the old man scp096 the Shy Guy and SCP
682 the hard to destroy reptile in their
many battles against the anomalous they
developed the incredible methodologies
and exceedingly advanced technology but
what good would any of it do when the
very center of our solar system decided
in an instant that rather being the
Lynch pin of our delicate cradle of life
it would instead be the horrible
instrument of all of our demises this
awful hypothetical was answered upon the
emergence of SCP 001 a terrible day also
known as when day breaks in the snap of
one's fingers half the world was plunged
into Terror and death rays of Stark red
light swept through the streets people
lucky enough to be in the shade or
inside buildings with a view to the
outside saw the people in the streets
seize up and begin to shriek in terrible
pain their skin sagged and their bones
liquefied their bodies dropped down to
the ground and coalesced into gurgling
wretching Puddles the color of melted
flesh those who saw this Abomination
happening would never forget it it would
stay with them for the rest of their
lives it would endure like a stain on
their retinas an after image burned into
the plasma of an old TV screen but
here's a slight consolation for most of
the human race the rest of their lives
wouldn't be that long the sudden
Insanity taking over the world caused
the SCP Foundation to do something
drastic step out of the Shadows
metaphorically speaking of course the
legendary Foundation motto had been
reversed they would die in the light so
that Humanity could live on in the dark
thankfully the very concept of the day
gave them one advantage while one side
of the Earth was effectively doomed the
second the process began the other side
had a 12-hour Head Start before the sun
turned its terrible eye to them sirens
went off in the middle of the night
waking people up groggy rubbing the
sleep from their eyes every television
and radio and internet anded device in
their home was playing the same message
direct from the SCP Foundation which now
had effectively commandeered the entire
US Government along with the rest of the
world it gave them directions to the
nearest Foundation containment site and
told them that if they didn't
immediately comply and find their way to
safety they would experience a terrible
death by sunrise and if you're at all
familiar with human beings you've
probably already predicted that they
didn't just calmly wrap themselves up
make their way to their cars and form an
orderly line to the various Foundation
containment sites located around them it
was in fact total pandemonium as the
solar clock ticked down slowly marking
off the seconds that anyone outside had
left to live the only human beings with
a meaningful Head Start began to go
insane in a number of varied and
interesting ways some who took the
situation seriously and acknowledged
that the sun was indeed going to wipe
out most of humanity simply cracked
under the pressure there were those who
went into totally catatonic States
rocking back and forth in the corner and
refusing to respond to any stimuli some
became erratic and violent with
unpredictable behavior that harmed
themselves and others after all what was
the point in acting normally anymore
when the complete crumbling of human
civilization was imminent and their only
hope was some shadowy organization
they'd never heard of some not heeding
the warning seriously enough and
prompted by greed and opportunism tried
to take advantage of the situation
financially some smashed Windows of
local stores and looted or broke into
the homes of neighbors who had already
fled in hopes of plowing their property
others were a little more creative
setting up shortterm everything must go
nighttime fire sales for their brands of
essential oils neotropics and
neutraceutical claiming all of them had
the power to ward off or cure the new
effects of the sun others completely
denied the possibility that any of this
was real and claimed that the messages
from the so-called SCP Foundation were
actually just a front to take away their
freedoms and trap them in underground
government camps they staunchly refused
to follow any of the safety guidelines
that the SCP Foundation put out claiming
if you try to take away my first
amendment rights you're going to take
away my second amendment rights while
riding around in their pickup trucks and
SUVs blasting Kid Rocks don't tell me
how to live at earsplitting volumes
naturally they had all melted into
screeching puddles of liquid flesh by
Sunrise some were not victims of their
own bizarre choices but were doomed by
the sudden terrible fear and panic of
the circumstances themselves
the highways were gridlocked cars stuck
as far as the eye could see so many had
rushed to escape during the initial wave
that means of Transport soon became
choke points like clogged arteries in a
dying man people do irrational things
when they're scared riots broke out in
the streets fighting killing burning
everyone hoping for some means of meager
control over a situation that had long
been out of any of their hands some were
too far away with not enough time to
close the distance what could they
really do but just sit around and wait
to die the hours marched on as the earth
made its slow turn towards the sun
leaving one decimated half in darkness
and the other a Sitting Duck for its
terrible effects hundreds of thousands
had made their way to the containment
sites and safely gotten inside but still
so many millions were left outside it
was a slaughterhouse one great big
Global meat grinder and every moment
that passed the the handle turned and
any humans left outside got just that
little bit closer to the grinding
nashing gears below site 19 being the
largest containment site on the
foundation books also became Humanity's
only Bastion it was the great hope of
escape from the horrors going on outside
the foundation had figured out so many
ways of counteracting deadly anomalous
forces before given enough time and
enough Personnel surely they could
figure out a solution to even this this
was however when the most startling
realization yet swept over all the
survivors those who were melted by the
sudden hostile Sun weren't dead they
were very much alive in fact but they
had been changed in both body and mind
what had once been humans now became
terrible beasts half melted gelatinous
nightmares that coagulated into even
bigger beasts they got into their head
that they were grateful for the
transformation that they had been
liberated from their old forms in the
old world they were something things so
much more now and they wanted everyone
else to join them in their Liberation
survivors outside the foundation
containment sites were systematically
hunted by these great masses of altered
flesh even though smart enough to cover
every inch of their bodies with clothes
to protect from the Sun to only move at
night to carry weapons were dragged out
by meaty tendrils from their refuge in
the basements and the lightless hearts
of buildings dragged into the Searing
gaze of the sun to melt to change
to coales into something greater it was
the inevitable fate of all of humanity
when most of the stragglers were dragged
out and changed the flesh masses started
turning their attention to the
foundation containment sites that were
keeping all these poor diluted people
from salvation they mounted offensives
against the bases which the foundation
with what remained of their Manpower and
advanced Weaponry did what they could to
repel the attacks but every single day
it got harder thank thankfully for the
people hold up at site 19 there was one
consolation out there to help SCP 999
the foundation was at war with the sun
and its terrible disciples and contrary
to many people's beliefs it takes more
than men equipment and bullets to win a
war 999 provided the essential element
that brought it all together morale hope
the will to go on even when it seemed
like all could be lost after a long day
of battling the fleshy Abominations At
The Gates Foundation guards mobile task
force members and even civilian
volunteers were drained and traumatized
by the horrors that they'd seen once a
day was over 999 would move among the
ranks cuddling up to them warding off
the despair that was easy to set in
during the downswing of a terrible
apocalypse like this without his
presence there would be no hope of
fighting that good fight so many of them
would have given up walked into the Sun
and joined the Monstrous Force they were
fighting after all they seemed happy
enough and it would certainly be easier
999 had become once again an
indispensable asset to the SCP
Foundation the solar betrayal may not
have been the Scarlet Kings doing well
as far as our current Intel suggests
anyway but he was playing a crucial part
in saving the world exactly as predicted
999 didn't fully understand what was
going on outside sometimes why there
seemed to be fewer people as the weeks
went on and why the people there seem so
sad all the time whenever he wasn't
helping them but he was more than happy
to help whatever the case many of the
humanoid and some even non-humanoid
anomalies which realistically posed no
harm to people inside the site were
released from their containment Chambers
they needed everyone and everything they
could get in what seemed like a
hopelessly one-sided fight against the
very concept of being outside many of
the larger vacated Chambers were now
filled with refugees from the outside
many of whom had lost everything and
everyone they'd ever known to the
horrors out there 999 made the rounds in
these areas regularly and through the
d-class Cs which had been repurposed
into more sleeping areas for the
thousands of desperate and terrified
refugees the adjustment to this new life
and to the knowledge of all secrets that
had been kept from them for all these
years wasn't exactly easy on their
psyches but spending time with that soft
yellow blob that seemed to smell exactly
like their favorite scent from the old
world made everything better he was a
savior in Dark Times slithering from
person to person giving hope where there
was none people opened up about their
problems and their fears which these
days were remarkably similar and though
999 couldn't reply for many was enough
just to feel like they were being
listened to he was a soft Blobby
shoulder to cry on and after day broke
everyone needed a good old-fashioned cry
however one day while wandering The Long
Dark corridors of site 19 he saw a
different kind of crying it was a woman
with an unfamiliar face probably one of
the rare new refugees balling her eyes
out to a foundation senior researcher
and an accompanying guard with an
assault rifle hot fat tears were rolling
down her dirty cheeks her shaking hands
clasped in prayer she was begging the
researcher and the guard to let her go
outside she said that her son was still
out there hiding away in the back room
of a bank where she used to work they
got separated she needed to go back and
find him sadly the researcher and the
guard told her that this was out of the
question official orders stated that
anyone outside the base at this time was
to be considered lost letting her go out
there to find her son would essentially
be condemning her to death no human
could go out there safely but of course
SCP 999 isn't by any definition a human
when night fell and everyone else was
hunkered down inside 999 found a small
crack in the wall and slithered out of
it it may not have been communicative in
the way way most humans were but 999 was
indeed an intelligent being and knew
intuitively that if it left through a
more obvious route its human caretakers
here at the SCP Foundation might try to
stop it and when it came to saving this
little boy 999 refused to let anyone
stop it 999 slithered out and through
the broken streets there were no bodies
of course it seemed even the dead could
be revived and assimilated through the
power of the sun talk about a mixed
Miracle but the broken down World
outside site 19 undeniably reflected the
pandemonium that took place here 999
would need to do his best to find the
little boy trapped out here before the
sun rose he lost a few hours even
finding his way to the nearest town
where it was safe to assume that the
little boy was trapped he saw those
things on the way there those moving
wailing mountains of melted human flesh
each talking and shattering to
themselves in a hundred different dead
voices 999 had been cross tested with
SCP 682 and still those monsters
frightened him he decided it would be
best to stay away from them and make
sure that they never saw him out of here
eventually 999 reached the town
similarly dilapidated and broken down in
the months since the world as we had all
known it disappeared in a ray of
terrible Sunshine more great gibbering
Blobs of Flesh patrolled the streets
looking for converts to integrate into
their biomass 999 could only hope it
wasn't already too late for the little
boy 999 discreetly slithered from
building to building until it could
identify one as this bank that the boy's
distraught mother had been mentioning it
thankfully had some awareness of what a
bank actually was from the years of
stressed Foundation employees telling it
about the money troubles they were
suffering outside of work it was another
great example of it paying to listen
eventually it did Slither into the
correct building and it heard the
extremely quiet whimpering of the Boy
Inside it could feel the sadness and the
fear radiating off of him as it was the
creature's natural instinct to help the
needy and he used those signals like a
homing beam to find the scared little
boy he'd hid an inside a broom closet
and was quietly weeping into his hands
he hadn't eaten in days and was only
surviving by drinking the filthy water
from the mop bucket sitting next to him
999 immediately embraced the boy
covering him in its healing energy until
the tears of the boy's face eventually
Dy 999 CED and chirped pleasantly until
the little boy was laughing again but
this momentary Joy was soon interrupted
a great heaving weight dragged itself
down the hall outside both 999 and the
boy could sense its monstrous presence
as it got closer they could hear all
those chattering voices those poisonous
Whispers when it passed the door they
heard it speaking its voice practically
vibrating with the hum of malicious
lunacy turn pretty flowers turn towards
the sun feel it on your face feel
yourself change and SLO and mix into us
become one with our army of One it must
be so lonely to be you Little Flower
walk into the Sun and be us 999 and the
boy remained silent in the broom closet
for hours as the great shape patrolled
the bank outside
searching for converts for victims at
times it seemed too frightening to even
breathe fearing that would be enough to
make the monster detect them it felt
like an eternity until the monster
eventually did slope off and leave them
in the comforting quiet and darkness of
the closet now they might be free 999
could escort the boy safely back to the
containment site and into the arms of
his terrified mother but when they
opened the door they saw a terrible
sight light in the distance pouring
Through the Windows and the glass double
doors it wouldn't be safe to go out that
way upon seeing this and putting
together what it meant the boy began to
cry he couldn't take another night in
the closet it was all going to Wither
from here until 999 had a wonderful idea
hours later when the foundation's guards
manned the turrets at the entrance of
site 19 waiting for the inevitable
onslaught of the melted flesh creatures
they tensed up seeing a blobbing
gelatinous form slithering towards them
in the distance the guards who' learned
the hard way from too many lost men that
it was better to be safe than sorry Drew
a bead on the distant shape and prepared
to fire when suddenly their Superior
raised a hand and said wait hold fire is
that
999 and it was they all stared in
astonishment as 999 chipper than ever
came towards them through the sun it
looked as though the opacity of its
yellow cytoplasm had increased but other
than that it was unaffected turns out
the sun couldn't melt what was already
melted the guards parted to allow 999
safe passage into the facility watching
an amazement and once it was inside 999
slime parted releasing its contents one
very relieved little boy it seemed
through turning up its own opacity 999
had given the boy safe Passage through
the Sun and back into the facility the
boy was saved it had won not long after
that there was a tear reunion between
mother and child and a brief flash of
Hope in this dark and terrible time 999
didn't stop to Basque of course it
returned to its duties keeping up staff
morale and helping the refugees heal
from the horrors they'd seen in its own
little way and for a lot of people SCP
999 really was saving the world or what
was left of it anyway oh and of course
if SCP 999 had won your hearts just like
it won ours you'd be pleased to know
that you can purchase your own adorable
highquality SCP 999 plushy at SCP
swag.com check the link in the
description to get your own trust us
having a 999 to cuddle really does make
any apocalypse a whole lot easier almost
all cross testing to kill or pacify SCP
682 had failed miserably if you haven't
seen it go watch our video on the
legendary hard tokill reptile to see
just how powerful and terrifying this
creature is it faced the gate Guardian
an SCP with a flaming sword hotter than
the sun capable of tearing your atoms to
shreds and came out fine in its face off
with a horrifying scp096 also known as
the shy guy it broke the Shy Guy's mind
and reduced it to gibbering despair even
SC scps with supposedly unlimited Powers
simply refused to engage the beast in
combat so when it was proposed that they
test 682 with SCP 999 a creature known
among Foundation staff as the tick
monster the idea was considered
laughable 682 had been burned suffocated
cut up incinerated and growled in the
faces of the Gods how could this
so-called Tickle Monster ever hope to
survive an encounter let alone win a
fight some even believe that this was
the last we'd see of SCP
999 but what makes this story truly
remarkable is that that isn't how this
played out as you'll soon discover SCP
999 is an amazing and unique SCP in and
of itself but its secret Origins and its
interactions with some other prominent
figures in the SCP Universe are what
make this humble slimy creature Beyond
extraordinary prepare yourself for the
heartwarming Yes you heard that right
the heartwarming story of SCP
999 several highly trained agents on 682
detail Place 999 into the immortal
lizard cell compared to the giant
reptilian sitting across from it 999
wasn't much to look at it's a large
orange amorphous blob of anomalous slime
weighing in at around 120 lb SCP 999 was
nothing compared to the monstrosity it
was supposed to face while its weight
has in the past caused minor injuries to
some of its human handlers it has never
caused serious or long- lasting damage
of any kind to a living thing even its
diet consists only of candy and sweets
with a particular preference for M&M's
and Necco Wafers it consumes these
treats through the cell membrane of its
slimy body much like an amoeba this
extremely stretchy membrane means the
creature is highly malleable including
the ability to stretch and flatten
itself out to a mere 2 cm thick at rest
the creature takes a dome likee shape
around 2 m wide and 1 m in height the
closest things the creature has to limbs
are preh henso pseudopods those are the
arm-like projections normally seen on
single- celled organisms of which it has
at least three the more you hear about
this utterly harmless creature the more
that matching it up with the pure
embodiment of absolute hatred known as
SCP 682 feels downright cruel in
absolute contrast to the misanthropic
attitudes of the reptile 999 loves
humans it has a playful doglike attitude
much like an overe excited puppy when
approached 999 will react with extreme
joy and Slither towards the nearest
person in order to interact it will leap
onto them using two of its three
prehensile pseudopods to hug the person
while the third nuzzles the person's
face emitting high-pitch cing and
gurgling noises throughout the creature
is apparently in every conceivable
fashion as even its odor has been
reported to smell just like the favorite
scent of whoever is smelling it examples
have included chocolate fresh laundry
bacon roses and Play-Doh it's almost
impossible to oversell just how beloved
and benevolent this strange creature is
it's one of the rare Sapient scps to
earn the safe class and it's allowed to
roam freely around its facility at all
times apart from a 1hour bedtime period
between 8: and 9:00 p.m. in the rare
instances that 999 has caused harm to a
worker at the facility it immediately
began to back away and contract its body
while whimpering in a kind of doglike
apology the closest the foundation has
ever come to having a real incident with
the creature was the time someone
accidentally FedEd a can of caffeinated
Cola causing it to become hyper for an
hour before becoming visibly queasy
you'll be relieved to know that it's
since made a full
recovery but what would happen when this
Whimsical creature is forced to go
toe-to-toe with the foundation's most
ill-tempered Monster the employees
observed in the test watched in suspense
as 999 began to enthusiastically Slither
towards 682 it's no surprise that after
being tortured and almost killed
hundreds of times during testing 682 had
grown jaded to the Cross test it was
regularly subjected to when it saw this
strange orange blob squelching across
the ground towards it it sighed and
groaned expecting the worst what is that
the creature asked of its gelatinous
guest SCP 999 began jumping up and down
in front of 682 like an excited puppy
creating a high-pitch squealing noise
just as it regarded all living things
682 thought the creature bouncing around
before it was disgusting and hardly
worth the effort to destroy was the
foundation even trying anymore with a
single vicious stomp 682 flattened the
friendly creature beneath one of its
feet observers were prepared to charge
in and liberate 999 from under 682s
claws but then something truly
unexpected happened the expression on
682s acid eaten face began to slowly
change it was beginning to smile
observers recorded a noise what they
thought could have been a chuckle as the
creature growled and
said what is this I
feel
good while The Observers looked on
stunned at what was happening 999 began
to Slither and crawl up from between
682s toes reformed on its scaly leg and
slithered up along its side until it
reached the neck there it began to
nuzzle like it had never nuzzled before
the results spoke for themselves 682 was
grinning and chuckling repeating a
phrase that the foundation never would
have imagined coming from
682 feel so
happy
happy happy just when you thought SCP
999 couldn't possibly be more adorable
you learn about its greatest power
bringing Joy anyone and anything that
comes into contact with the creature
even in passing will experience a kind
of mild Euphoria as one's contact with
the creature is prolonged this
overwhelming sense of Joy increases and
continues long after you've separated
from it prolonged contact has completely
cured depression anxiety and PTSD along
with a number of other conditions
including rage and antisocial
personality disorders serial killers
practically become Saints after coming
into prolonged contact with 999 and in
that moment 682 was no exception and
there truly does not appear to be no
exceptions while causing happiness and
joy isn't a dangerous weapon when it
comes to SCP 999 it is an extremely
powerful one and what's more scp-999
also appears to have an innate sense for
those who need its help most with a
particular affection for the hurt and
the unhappy the creature appears to be a
true altruist on a fundamental level
even risking its own safety to help
humans during dangerous containment
breaches in one dramatic instance 999
leaped into the air to block a bullet
from making contact with a member of
Staff as a result the creature is pretty
much universally loved by all members of
foundation staff it's the one SCP who
has never made trouble for anyone back
in scp-682's containment cell the Beast
was still smiling and laughing as 999
rubbed against its neck it was an event
so strange so unprecedented that The
Observers and attendance felt like they
were hallucinating for a few minutes the
monster kept dreamily repeating the word
happy but then suddenly the creature
began to to enter a fit of
uncontrollable booming laughter it
rolled onto its back slamming its huge
tail against the door it had just Fallen
victim to one of 99's favorite pastimes
tickle fights hence how it earned its
Tickle Monster nickname among staff the
tickle fight continued until 682
appeared to tire and fall asleep with a
smile still on its face after 15 minutes
of inactivity two d-class Personnel were
commanded to enter and retrieve SCP 999
from the containment cell they did so
successfully but as soon as 999 was
removed 682 roused from its Slumber and
released a powerful psychic attack from
its entire body while laughing
maniacally it rendered all Personnel
within a certain distance incapacitated
as they collapsed in fits of laughter
allowing 682 to escape and go on a
violent Rampage however in spite of this
999 showed no fear and helped save some
of the bystanders as security officers
subdued and recaptured 682 and even
after all of this 999 showed no hard
feelings towards 682 and indicated a
desire to play again it's a creature
whose capacity for love is so Limitless
that it's practically immune to fear
which is all well and good because the
true enemy that 999 is destined to face
is infinitely more powerful and
terrifying than 682 could ever hope to
be what is this monster and why should
999 have to face it someday the answers
to these questions all lie in the true
origins of SC p999 available only to
those with level five clearance and
Beyond it's a perfect example of how
something good can come from the darkest
places there would be no SCP 999 without
scp-231-7 SCP 231 was a collection of
seven girls all impregnated by horrific
nightmares in a ritual performed by a
cult known as the children of the
Scarlet King each of these girls over
the years that followed gave birth to
some of the most horrific monsters
imagin able one of which According to
some was SCP
682 these beings were manifested by the
Scarlet King a powerful interdimensional
nightmare God believed to be behind a
great deal of the darkness and horror
present within R and many other
dimensions Foundation hups have declared
the Scarlet King to be the greatest
existing threat to the Multiverse at
large an SCP 231 was his latest direct
interaction with our universe the only
surviving member of SCP p231
scp-231-7 gave birth in secret but she
didn't give birth to a monster she gave
birth to SCP 999 a being of pure
goodness that's right the nicest kindest
cuddliest SCP of all is the direct
descendant of a being that's essentially
the dark God of all evil feel free to
take a moment to absorb that the
creature even healed the girl who
birthed it and allowed her to return to
normal life with her family one once
more from its first moments SCP 999 was
making positive changes to the world
around it and according to ancient texts
from a Scarlet King align culture known
as the deas SCP 999 is still very much
in its infancy yet it already has the
power to pacify its monstrous siblings
like the aformentioned
682 it's believed According to some
prophecies and Foundation theories that
the power of SCP 999 will grow
exponentially as it
matures why does matter well it's
believed by some that one day 999 will
grow powerful enough to overthrow not
only its own monstrous siblings but the
thought to be unstoppable Scarlet King
himself not through violence or hate but
through the pure force of happiness and
love burning out the darkness and
purifying the corrupted while the humble
SCP 999 rarely outshines its frightening
competitors to those truly in the no 999
is one of the most powerful and valuable
CPS in existence and may be the greatest
asset in the foundation's Arsenal for
the war against dangerous anomalous
activity after all what could strike
more fear into their hearts than the
knowledge that it might be love rather
than Firepower that finally dethrones
the Scarlet King and for the knowledge
that it may one day save everything we
know from a fate so much worse than
death with nothing but affection for
everyone and everything it's worth
offering thanks to the little orange
blob or at least an extra pack of M&M's
before bedtime the Scarlet King is a
really bad guy he's a giant
interdimensional nightmare God intent on
breaching our reality and Wrecking
terrible havoc on everything we know and
love he's been responsible for Untold
suffering and Chaos across countless
worlds timelines and layers of reality
to many he's even somewhat of a final
boss to the SCP Foundation and just when
you think he couldn't get any worse it
turns out that he's also a deadbeat dad
not only did the Scarlet King once have
a cult literally named the children of
the Scarlet King before it was destroyed
by Dr Monto and the SCP Foundation he
also had at least seven actual children
each one is speculated to be a powerful
anomaly but it's tough to find concrete
answers as to who or what exactly most
of them are so today we're putting on
our researcher hats and digging deep
into the foundation's lore to present
our theories on the potential progeny of
the SCP foundation's greatest enemy and
if nothing else we may finally be able
to get this dark lord of all evil to
start paying all the child support he
probably owes by now first if you're not
well versed in Scarlet King Vore you may
be wondering how exactly does an evil
chaos God have kids is there a Scarlet
Queen out there who prefers to stay out
of the Limelight the answer isn't quite
that simple and it has everything to do
with SCP 231 and Big Red's most devoted
cult
the non-biological Children of the
Scarlet King they kidnapped a group of
seven girls and performed a number of
dark rituals that resulted in them
becoming vessels for the Scarlet King's
seven terrible kids these seven girls
have become known as SCP 231 anyone who
accesses those files and trust us they
aren't a pretty sight will find that the
containment procedures mostly involved
performing the infamous mon talk
procedure on the surviving girls to keep
them from giving birth six of the Seven
Brides have given birth to nightmares
Beyond Comprehension and are now dead
with only one still remaining
successfully contained but here at the
SCP Foundation you need to learn to
comprehend the
incomprehensible according to a
classified document SCP 231 May
technically be a neutralized anomaly
without us even knowing and incidentally
this gives us our most certain answer on
the children of the Scarlet King on this
one the Apple fell very very far from
the tree according to the secret
document SCP 999 that's right the
adorable Tickle Monster is the seventh
child of the Scarlet King he must be so
disappointed that everyone's favorite
little blob didn't want to join the
family business of absolute evil for
anyone who doesn't know SCP 999 is a
slimy yellow entity that only seems
capable of absolute compassion it brings
joy to everyone in its presence and with
prolonged exposure it can even cure
disorders like PTSD anxiety and
depression he's so good at this that he
even cured
scp-231-7 his defacto mother of her
trauma and allowed her to return happily
to her family after some amnestic
treatment the Scarlet King has another
good reason to be ashamed of his
cheerful Blobby son ancient DVID
prophecy dictates that SCP 999 May
someday become so powerful that is force
of absolute love and good overwhelms the
Scarlet King's evil and chaos think of
him as the Luke Skywalker to the Scarlet
King's Darth Vader though we probably
can't expect a cool lightsaber battle
between them anytime soon how
disappointing so if SCP 999 is the quiet
sensitive black sheep of the Scarlet
family who's The Golden Child who makes
his evil father proud the real chip off
the old block that would be our dear
reptilian friend SCP 682 the malicious
lizard heavily implied to be a child of
the Scarlet King if you know literally
anything about 682 your reaction to
finding out that he's the spawn of
Cruelty personified is probably yeah
that makes sense just as SCP 999 is the
Scarlet King's innocent optimistic young
child 682 is kind of like his edgy
teenager still in the middle of a
misanthropic phase he shows no sign of
leaving anytime soon the fact that 682
appears to find anything about the world
around him utterly disgusting seems to
be a trade he inherited from his dear
old dad and the fact he seems seems
pretty much impossible to kill also
lends Credence to the popular Theory
he's got nightmare God blood running
through his veins 682 has also started
displaying a particular hatred for 999
ever since an incident where 999 tickled
him into submission so family dinners
are probably extra awkward for these two
999 and 682 are the most certain
children but that still leaves us with
five more children to identify it's
worth remembering that the waters are
murkier from here on in but we've
searched far and wide through the
foundation archives to find possible
answers if your interpretation differs
remember that it's just a theory an SCP
explained Theory thankfully we do have
some assistance here the taale DUS and
blood hinted at what each of the seven
children of the Scarlet King represents
and that may help us narrow down our
choices here to put things into
perspective it's believed that 682 was
the fourth child to be born representing
Wrath and 999 was the seventh
representing hope according to this Tale
the first of the seven children
represents dominion and as a result is
skilled in the ways of war and has the
power to lead the king's forces to
Victory according to One Foundation
theorist this child could potentially be
SCP 239 also known as the witch child
this entity is so powerful that as part
of its normal containment procedures
it's eternally kept in a coma why
because this seemingly normal child has
dominion over reality and can change it
to her whims her thoughts are so
powerful that just her brain waves can
damage physical matter and she can make
things disappear or manifest in an
instant she's also impossible to kill
with skin that's almost totally
impenetrable much like SCP 682 she's
also frighteningly strong in both the
offense and defense department we're
talking about such a powerful telepath
that Dr clef has campaigned for her
immediate termination just because it's
safer that way this is certainly a
frightening wonderin that the Scarlet
king would be proud to call his daughter
next the second child according to the
prophecy this child represents longing
the child has the power to bring forth
armies which will help the Scarlet King
in his Conquest for this we actually
have a pretty unconventional Theory SCP
029 also known as the daughter of
Darkness if the name alone wasn't enough
to suggest that she's got an extremely
Sinister father she also fits the
profile of being very aggressive and
incredibly hard to kill but even more
damning is her connections to the
symbology of longing one of her most
dangerous Powers is causing men to fall
into almost trans-like Devotion to her
after spending time around her they're
suddenly willing to murder in her honor
strangling their victims in hopes of
raising Ki the Hindu God of destruction
whom has many similarities to the
Scarlet King she certainly fits the bill
of someone capable of raising armies in
the Dark Lord's name one strike against
our Scarlet King connection theory is
that the file States the daughter of
Darkness was first discovered in India
which wouldn't match up with the other
information we know to be fact however
while this is a long shot given the
sensitive nature of everything involving
the Scarlet King it's extremely possible
that false information was supplied to
bury the connection considering the
coverups and lies involving anomalies
like SCP 1000 this certainly isn't an
unprecedented move on the part of the
foundation next the third child this
child is associated with all things
desolation implying destruction fire
ashes pestilence and death across the
battlefield when it comes to spreading
destruction and Death on a mass scale
one particular SCP comes to mind SCP
058 the Heart of Darkness this creature
has Scarlet King written all over it
it's it's evil it's mysterious it's
pretty much impossible to kill and it
causes Mass casualties every time it
escapes its containment chamber it
causes fires whips people to death with
its razor sharp tendrils and sprays
highly corrosive acid from its scorpion
likee tail and it's even red given that
we know for a fact this entity suddenly
emerged out of something that's now been
expunged from the records in an
undisclosed site it's extremely possible
that the entity 058 came from was SCP
then goes into more detail saying that
this child is powerful in the ways of
magic and is able to use their abilities
to cause great destruction here we have
another unconventional proposal what if
child number five wasn't actually a
child but children that's because we
think this description perfectly fits
SCP
1765 the nightmarish reality warping
sisters who we think may actually be
Triplets of the Scarlet King's fifth
bride now hear us out these are actually
some of the most powerful enemies the
foundation has ever attempted to contain
and we know nothing about their paast
before being bound to a few objects by
the Serpent's hand these sadistic
reality warpers are so devastatingly
powerful that the only action the
foundation can take against them is
letting them have free Reign Over the
containment site they currently inhabit
all the foundation can do is hope they
never get Bor of tormenting the people
inside as we all know the Scarlet King
despises science progress and order so
perhaps a perfect punishment for the
foundation in his many eyes is giving
them a taste of their own medicine the
sisters though particularly their ring
leader are a perverse shadow of the
foundation's love of the scientific
method they take these methods and use
them for an activity that the Scarlet
King finds much more enjoyable
tormenting and killing people whenever
these crafty triplets set their mind to
it their horrifically powerful magic is
able to cause massive Devastation just
like the prophecy for the fifth bride's
Offspring dictates and finally the sixth
child of the scarlot king the concept
associated with this one is hidden
meaning it can change its face and walk
unnoticed through creation it's also
said to have the responsibility of
opening the ways between worlds and
allowing the war to end all wars to
first begin there have been a huge
number of guesses for this spot with
some even suggesting SCP 05 55 the
anti-em but since we're having fun here
we also want to make an even Wilder
suggestion we pait that the sixth child
of the Scarlet King is Allison Shia also
known as LS and the black queen the most
powerful member of the Serpent's hand we
get it we have a lot of explaining to do
but hear us out Allison Shia is a member
of the Serpent's hand or technically
many members multiple versions of her
exist across parallel dimensions in the
SCP Multiverse they're mostly all
estranged Daughters of foundation
researcher Dr Charles KS this
estrangement leads them to collaborate
in The Wanderer Library the secret base
of the Serpent's hand to conduct raids
on the foundation in Revenge but what if
the leader of these alternate Allison
had an ulterior motive because in the
infinite number of possibilities offered
by the Multiverse this one was not the
daughter of Charles gears but the
Scarlet King she's merely using the pain
of her counterparts to manipulate them
into accomplishing her true father's
goal undermining the SCP Foundation
let's break it down the hidden child is
prophesies to walk unnoticed through
creation not only does Alison Chow
appear human the use of SCP 268 a news
boy cap that causes the wearer to become
unnoticed allows her to walk anywhere
through creation without being detected
but most importantly of all the hidden
child is said to be the one who opens
the way for the Scarlet King's entrance
into our Dom Di menion and Allison Chow
has access to the wanderer's library an
unfettered access point between
Dimensions if one of the infinite
Allison was the secret daughter of the
Scarlet king would the wanderer's
library not be a perfect way for him to
leave his own Dimension and enter ours
she could be the final piece he needs
hidden under the nose of the foundation
and the Serpent's hand making all the
secret power plays to allow for the
Scarlet King's eventual bloody revenge
on our world
unless of course SCP 999 the family
disappointment stops him first we
realize that some of these theories may
seem surprising but when it comes to the
anomalous especially the Scarlet King
the only thing you can ever expect is
the unexpected do you agree with our
theories if not who do you think are the
children of the Scarlet King let us know
down in the comments one thing is for
certain we hope we never meet any of the
terrible tyrants nasty children except
the Tickle Monster of course he can hang
with us any time SCP 999 also known as
the Tickle Monster it's one of the most
adorable beloved and undeniably
wholesome anomalies ever to exist in the
SCP foundation's Containment facilities
its mere presence can cause joy and
comfort cure depression and other mental
illnesses and even sometimes cause
violent and unpredictable creatures to
really mellow out if you're a fan of
this channel chances are that you're a
big fan of SCP 9992 but that doesn't
mean everyone is on board as we all know
there are plenty of entities and groups
in the SCP universe that are downright
evil and as a result would love to see
this little blob of pure joy crushed to
a pulp or sacrificed to a cosmic horror
but you can't ever underestimate wait a
second is that a Containment Breach
alarm all Foundation staff members
report to the affected cell immediately
it looks like an scps escape containment
and is now in our world world that's
right SCP 999 has broken out of SCP
Foundation control and now you can
finally have a tickle monster of your
very own in plush form this super
adorable plush from SCP swag is 11 in of
huggable squeezable joy and now that the
Tickle Monster is out of containment you
can bring it into your own home tickle
monster plushies are available for
pre-order now and all orders made in the
next 10 days also get a special limited
first edition card worldwide shipping is
also available so go to SCP swag.com
right now and pre-order your own Tickle
Monster and let us know in the comments
what SCP anomalies you want to see in
plush form next but as we were saying
you can't ever underestimate SCP 999 not
only has it tickled SCP 682 into
submission there are also certain
theories floating around the foundation
that it will one day grow so powerful
its forces of pure goodness and joy can
overthrow the Scarlet King himself
that's why today we're throwing the
Tickle Monster into a kind of Royal
Rumble with all the baddest dudes the
foundation has ever encountered and
we're going to give our theories on how
SCP 999 might somehow find the good and
even the blackest of Hearts first scp096
the shy guy a killing machine so brutal
direct and opaque in its motives that
some have even questioned whether it
actually has sentience however we'd
personally stake our claim that it does
when a photo of this Savage Beast was
taken with SCP 978 the desire camera a
camera camera that shows the deepest
desire of its subjects it revealed that
the shy guy secretly just had the desire
to disappear not only does this suggest
that the monster may not actually like
killing people but the very idea that it
can have a desire also implies some
level of intelligence but how would
scp-999 enter the mix well we know that
096 is an anxious creature it spends the
majority of its time just pacing itself
cell and when someone sees its face it
begins sobbing uncontrollably before
entering its rage state does this sound
like a happy entity to you if the shy
guy encountered 999 at its full
joy-giving power we'd personally think
that it might finally chill out a little
perhaps it'd take a moment to breathe
and contemplate life a little more maybe
it would wonder why it's so ashamed of
its face and feels the need to hunt down
and kill anyone who sees it after all
there are much uglier anomalies like SCP
106 he's the next Monster to join this
this weird wild cage match against SCP
999 while 096 is violent 106 is
downright malevolent he's not just
sentient but extremely intelligent the
old man loves causing pain and suffering
for his own perverse pleasure just as
much as Heavy Hitters like SCP 682 so
surely 999 would have its work cut out
for it here well not necessarily there
are two leading theories about who 106
actually is one being the Scranton
Theory and the other the Corporal
Lawrence Theory the first dictates that
106 is the result of Dr Robert Scranton
physically and mentally transformed by
his time in SCP 3001 the terrifying red
reality the second theory was that he
was a World War I Soldier known as
Corporal Lawrence whose anomalous
encounter in the trenches turned him
into the Beast he is today in either
case he's a man shaped by pain and
anomalous trauma much like 096 the the
desire camera revealed an insight into
106's mind his greatest desire consists
of him walking across a field towards an
old house where an old woman smiles and
waits for him many believe this old
woman to be his estranged wife perhaps
an encounter with SCP 999 would cause
106's sism to Abate reminding him of the
humanity he once had maybe he become a
kindly old man in the aftermath who
prefers worther Originals to violence
and spinning long rambling Yarns about
the war rather than chasing people
around his terrifying pocket Dimension
it's a thought so sweet it could almost
make you sick thankfully one of our
favorite doctors is next on the list
specifically the plague doctor SCP 049
while he definitely isn't as dangerous
or malicious as either of his
predecessors 049 has racked up quite a
body count in his hundreds of years of
operations he sees pestilence everywhere
he goes except within and can kill with
a mere touch however his deadly touch
only seems to apply to non-anomalous
animals and humans not other anomalies
so he definitely couldn't harm 999 and
the Tickle Monster conversely could
definitely touch him back while the
plague doctor is the serious type he
might not be able to keep his bedside
manner after a serious tickling and we'd
be more than willing to hedge our bets
on him having the laugh of an Angel well
049 may have folded in the face of 99's
tickling wrath our next contestant is as
solid as a rock well technically as
solid as concrete that's because it's
SCP 173 also known as the sculpture or
the peanut it shows no emotions and
murders anything that blinks in its
Presence by snapping its neck but 999
doesn't even have bones let alone a neck
so SCP 173 has nothing with which to
threaten this happy little blob and what
about SCP 99's counter offense iive if
the Tickle Monster got its slime all
over SCP 173 it might finally reform
this statuesque serial killer through
prolonged exposure maybe after that 173
will finally give relaxing neck massages
rather than snapping them but while the
sculpture may be intimidating it's
nothing compared to an unkillable Mass
murdering blade Master right of course
we're talking about SCP
076 also known as able no matter how
many times he gets put down He Keeps
coming back with unparalleled skills in
physical combat and the ability to pull
huge blades out of thin air he also
appears to be fueled by pure Unstoppable
rage so how on Earth could our adorable
little Tickle Monster possibly go
toe-to-toe with a swordsman who cuts
through Elite Mobile task force soldiers
like a hot knife through a d-class much
like SCP 106 it seems like a lot of
ael's rage is rooted in a deep pain
caused by his past if he truly is the
biblical able it's likely that his rage
stems from being the very first murder
victim betrayed and killed by his
brother Cain now known as SCP 073
spending time with SCP 999 might finally
calm him down enough to actually work
through some of these issues and come to
a sense of closure maybe with SCP 999 at
his side Abel could attend some therapy
sessions with Foundation psychologists
until he finally felt as though he'd
moved past his murderous urges perhaps
even working up to family counseling
with Kane he could then re-enter society
and reapply his expert knife skills and
become a Bobby fle style celebrity chef
except one who could actually Flay you
if you got on his bad side but let's
talk about an SCP that's frankly
dangerous to even discuss I am of course
referring
to SCP 2521 okay great I'm not dead
wonderful let's carry on 2521 is
attracted to any information about it
written WR or spoken it will immediately
appear upon the creation of this
information and steal either the
information itself or the person
disseminating it in the case of verbal
words if someone were to pass SCP 999 a
fact sheet about SCP 2521 it would
inevitably manifest and prepare to throw
down but perhaps the positive influence
of SCP 999 would change as cp25 21's
tune rather than obsessively stealing
information about itself the being May
instead finally open up and speak about
itself we might even learn some
interesting things like the fact it used
to have a bowling team with SCP 106 and
SCP 049 he also loves knitting oh come
on not
again now how about we go for something
a little closer to human please SCP 082
Ferdinand the cannibal a huge ogre-like
humanoid that has a penchant for
pathological lies and also devouring
human heads and well the rest of the
body on and well the rest of the body
too if he's worked up enough of an
appetite he's super strong and has a
hide so thick that seemingly no weapon
can penetrate it how could s CP 999
possibly go around with a behemoth like
this lucky for 999 fernan has an
extremely cheerful temperament if a
potential victim can keep him amused
often listening and playing along with
his elaborate fantasies it massively
increases is their chance of survival
and considering SCP 999 is literally a
good vibes machine there's a good chance
that it keep Ferdinand so amused that
the thought of getting angry wouldn't
even cross his mind once again little
SCP 999 takes home the W but what about
a real stist a truly heartless monster
whose commitment to focused endless
cruelty is genuinely unparalleled we're
talking about the being from SCP
3999 this terrifyingly powerful reality
warper hasn't racked up scores of
victims because it prefers the quality
of suffering over quantity it'll select
a single victim trap them in their own
personal hell and spend a literal
eternity conceiving every possible
torture and torment to break the spirit
and body of the victim never giving them
the luxury of death however if an entity
could turn the tables and break the
spirit of SCP 3999 it would be SCP 999
picture it thousands of years with the
monster tries everything it can to break
the tickle Monster's Spirit only to find
its own spirit being broken as scp-999
doesn't succumb to any of it and
continues to project love and kindness
throughout could you imagine anything
more frustrating for a creature like
3999 eventually it would probably get so
frustrated that it would let 999 go and
find some hapless Foundation researcher
to torture instead going up against a
single anomalous being regardless of its
power is one thing but taking on an
entire group is another challenge for
SCP 999 what if 999 became trapped in
SCP 3008 the endless Ikea surrounded by
the deadly staff in the middle of the
night our theory is that the positive
presence of SCP 999 would really help
the nightmarish malform staff of this
accursed Ikea turn their lives around
and start creating a more positive work
environment around the store rather than
trying to chase survivors trapped inside
the store and beat them to death they
would instead help them find the ideal
furniture for enhancing their lifestyle
if they ever managed to escape the
building 999 would help them go from
horrifying to helpful in no time it'd be
so nice in there that the survivors
wouldn't even want to leave but what
about groups of Interest let's say the
chaos Insurgency has broken into a
containment site in another one of its
classic raids against the foundation
would a group of elite chaos Insurgency
operatives be able to take down the
Tickle Monster we think not well these
anomaly stealing militants may be
hardcore compared to your average Joe
they're nowhere near as hateful or
irredeemable as the likes of 682 or
106 chances are if they've spent any
amount of time around 999 they'd
experience a sudden sense of mellowness
and begin to rethink all of their poor
life choices but what about the GOC
those government Stooges obsessed with
killing any anomaly they can get their
hands on personally we theorize that a
runin with SCP 999 and the immensely
positive feelings it causes cause them
to reevaluate their entire philosophy on
the anomalies they encounter and lead
them to restructure their entire
organization from the ground up perhaps
they'd even promote SCP 999 to the
position of under Secretary General and
perhaps even change the meaning of the
group's acronym to givers of Cuddles in
honor of their new leader and direction
we can dream right but let's end this
dream with a nightmare the Scarlet King
the most dangerous being in the entire
Multiverse who is also strongly believed
to be SCP 99's real father H awkward can
ultimate good someday defeat ultimate
Evil according to ancient diate
prophecies a terrifying historical
culture that worshiped the Scarlet King
yes it can if given the time and
nurturing it needs to reach full power
how exactly would that battle play out
well it's difficult to even theorize but
chances are it'd be a battle of truly
biblical proportions and if ever the
Scarlet King did breach our Dimension
it's safe to say that you'd want your
own little SCP 999 close at hand and now
you can go to SCP swag.com and pre-order
a tickle Monster Plush of your very own
it doesn't even need any anomalous
powers to bring you a ridiculous amount
of Joy orders placed in the next 10 days
get a special limited first edition card
so don't wait get yours now before
they're all gone life at the SCP
Foundation isn't exactly made up of
sunshine and rainbows it's less of a
good vibes kind of place and more more
of a this is the solemn work we do as we
stand between Humanity in the vast
unfeeling unknowable realm of mystery
and darkness sure sometimes there's a
magic vending machine or a teddy bear
doctor but most of the time the
foundation's findings are a lot more
bite than they are bar thankfully
there's the C portion of that Infamous
acronym contain they keep their bizarre
astounding findings locked up tight
where they can't catch an unsuspecting
innocent off guard and oh hey there
little buddy it's okay you didn't mean
to scare me relax everyone it's just SCP
999 one of the only contained
Curiosities allowed to roam freely
around the halls of the foundation just
look at this guy has a sentient mass of
translucent orange slime ever been so
cute you want some chocolate buddy okay
here you go it's incredible really that
the place that houses a neck snapping
sculpture in a haunted chest playing
machine could also be the home of such a
delightful little blob you know now that
I think of it it's amazing amazing that
being in the vicinity of unspeakable
Horrors day after day has never put a
damper on 99's positive attitude he's
got the persistent cheerful disposition
of a labador puppy but how well would
SCP 99's inherent wholesomeness hold up
against one of the most wicked anomalies
contained by the SCP Foundation what
would happen if the lightest of the
light a slimy piece of pure goodness
came up against a deep dark evil not the
omnicidal Rage of SCP 682 we all know
how that went but something quieter well
let's find out SCP 999 was having the
best day of its life to be fair every
single day was the best day of the
tickle Monster's life surpassed only by
the day that followed and the one after
that and how could it not be a good life
at the SCP Foundation when there were so
many friends to play with treats to eat
and so much to explore SCP 999 was
enjoying a hearty bowl of M&M's picking
out and eating the the orange ones its
favorites first when a familiar figure
walked into its pen Dr Jack brigh who
frequently came by to see the Tickle
Monster when he was having a
disappointing day usually because the
higher-ups had reprimanded him for
breaking the rules yet again SCP 999 CED
delightfully at the sight of its visitor
slithering over to Dr bright and
enveloping him in an enthusiastic hug Dr
bright immediately began to laugh as the
creatur's euphoric influence took effect
hey glad there are no feelings about the
time I ate a piece of
you he giggled as 999 patted his face
affectionately with one of its pseudo
pods a thanks that really takes the
sting out of getting the no chainsaws
Hammer brought down on me again he
patted the slime with his own hand in
return and satisfied that it had
sufficiently cheered him 999 ooz back
over to its breakfast to finish
consuming the sugary goodness oh I
almost forgot Dr brgh pulled something
out of his lab coat pocket it was a
small can of cola appealingly shiny in
the light want some SCP 999 gurgled
curiously and approached Dr brigh to
inspect the can he popped it open with
an inviting Fizz and offered some
fortunately Dr rhs was walking by at
that exact moment don't you dare she
snatched the can out of her colleague's
hand you remember what happened last
time 999 can't tolerate caffeine or
carbonation Dr bright pouted like a
petulant child but I wanted to see it
bounce do I need to add another rule to
the list Dr rhs crossed her arms or are
you going to behave yourself GH fine
whatever I'll find something else to do
Dr brigh rolled his eyes and left SCP
99's pen with a final friendly wave at
the creature sensing Dr rh's stress the
Tickle Monster nuzzled her leg with an
inquisitive gurgle she smiled
indulgently and gave the Slime a hug
before she followed Dr brigh down the
hall keeping an eye out for any more
potentially disruptive Antics satisfied
at having cheered everyone up SCP 999
went back to its bowl of candy and
devoured the remaining Treats but then
there was nothing left to eat and no one
in the room to visit or play with what
was a lovable slime to do why explore of
course SCP 999 had the freedom to roam
all over the foundation site until
bedtime that is and it loved oozing down
the Halls looking for friends to greet
and strangers to meet after all a
stranger is just a friend that the
Tickle Monster hasn't tickled yet as the
Slime slid along the floor it took the
time to say hello to everyone at passed
by bumping them nudging them or in the
case of Josie the half cat very gently
petting her head with one of its pseudo
pods the cat purred and 999 responded by
vibrating its gelatinous body producing
a soft purr of its own then Josie was
distracted by a dust particle drifting
through a beam of light and darted off
to chase it so the Tickle Monster
continued on its way looking for
something new and fun to do it spotted
the perfect new activity two guards were
walking into one of the sealed
containment rooms a room that the Jolly
little slime had never been inside of
before now was the perfect chance to
investigate and maybe play tickle
wrestling with the guards along the way
it had to act fast though the door was
beginning to close rearranging its body
999 squished itself into a long thin
line sliding quickly through the crack
in the door just before it shot this new
room was very messy much messier than
9999 was allowed to keep its own room
any spilled chocolate milk or smeared
cupcake frosting was either cleaned up
by staff or slurped up by the slime
itself but in this room there was thick
black liquid dripping down all of the
walls some of it arranging itself into
patterns and words though 999 couldn't
read what they said the guards hadn't
noticed the tickle Monster's presence
yet and it kept still excited to give
them a wonderful surprise when they
turned around and saw that it had
followed them inside but they didn't
turn around they were completely focused
on something in front of them what was
it it was a thick glass case that looked
as if it was about to fall apart at any
moment inside there was a mask a
porcelain mask of a frowning face with
that same strange dark fluid dripping
from its eye and mouth holes you know
the procedure right one guard said he
was holding a brand new glass case shiny
and completely empty of course I do the
other scoffed it's my first time with
this anomaly not my first day on the job
just open it up and take the mask out
and put it in here he tapped on the case
he was holding as quickly as possible
yeah I just said I know the less
experienced guard grumbled don't
patronize me he reached towards the
decaying case and prepared to unlock it
wait Did you hear that hear what I
thought i' heard never mind scp-999
vibrated with excitement would they give
it some well-deserved attention maybe
play a game but no the guard wasn't
talking about the eager orange pal
behind him he was feeling the influence
of something much more Sinister do you
want me to do it the more experienced
guard offered no just you you really
don't hear that that whispering his
colleague just shook his head fine it's
just been a long week I guess he sighed
and popped the case open reaching for
the mask inside as soon as his fingers
made contact with the porcelain surface
the black goo dripping onto his skin
where he should have been wearing
protective gloves gloves his expression
shifted his eyes went blank like someone
sleepwalking lost in a dream even as
their body moved in the waking World
Frank what are you waiting for the other
guard nudged him but Frank said nothing
he delicately lifted the mask out of the
glass box and before anyone could stop
him placed the frowning white face over
his own only it wasn't frowning anymore
as soon as its featur slipped over
Frank's covering him erasing him its
mouth curved into a malicious smile SM
Frank what the hell are you doing the
guard cried out as the man he had once
known grabbed hold of his shoulders not
Frank anymore a voice came out from
behind the ceramic lips but it was
different cruel cold ancient Frank's
gone out I'm afraid and he won't be back
anytime soon the guard tried to break
away from the masked man's grasp trying
to reach for the Emergency alarm to
signal that the containment change had
gone G horribly wrong but the mask
shoved him into the wall hard the guard
hit his head and slumped to the ground
unconscious and likely concussed well
scp-999 has had just about enough of all
this it hated seeing anyone hurt
especially humans and clearly its help
was sorely needed to make things better
it couldn't tell exactly what had upset
the man in The Mask so much that he was
acting this way but he knew one thing
that always cheered humans up it was
time for a bit of good old-fashioned
tickle wrestling SCP 999 hurled itself
across the room enveloping Frank's Body
from his feet to his neck and it began
tickling him as it did the force of 99's
tackle sent Frank's Body careening
towards the ground and when it landed
with a heavy thud The Mask flew off his
face and skittered across the floor now
that I could see Frank's face 999 looked
for signs of laughter of Joy but Frank
was dead asleep eyes closed Jaws slack
his heart was still still beating but he
wouldn't wake up confused concerned and
upset at what it had witnessed in this
new room the Slime slithered along the
floor toward the mask that had caused so
much trouble it seemed to be staring at
999 with its dark vacant eyes it didn't
look like a toy in fact it looked like
something that the Slime should avoid
touching but it couldn't help but notice
that the face had changed back to a
frown could 999 really leave the mask
there on the floor frowning like that
the ti pickle monster couldn't help it
with a soft greeting by way of a
high-pitched cing noise it reached out
to the mask and picked it up though the
Slime creature didn't have a traditional
face for the mask to sit on top of its
influence quickly grabbed hold of 99's
gelatinous frame it stopped moving
stopped gurgling stopped looking at the
world through rose-colored glasses right
now SCP 999 was being piloted by the
possessive mask and it was looking for a
way out once it escaped container
it could find a new host a proper host
with arms legs and a mouth but for now
this undignified vehicle would have to
do it took the mask some time to learn
how to Pilot this strange soft body with
its malleable form and odd methods of
moving itself around the room but it
slowly adjusted and wearing the
silhouette of the Tickle Monster like a
disguise oozed out of its containment
room and into the Hall staff walking by
barely even noticed 99's presence they
were too preoccupied with their work
they were used to seeing it and giving
it a polite nod but most of them didn't
have the time to stop and say a proper
hello at this time of day perhaps this
would be easy after all the mask had
lost its chosen host but found something
even better the perfect cover and the
chance to hide in plain sight it could
take in the lay of the land scope out
potential exit routes and ideally slide
out of foundation custody completely
unnoticed The Mask began to smile at the
thought as the mask steered as CP 999
body around the sight A peculiar feeling
began to gnaw at the back of its mind
like an itch it couldn't quite scratch
something irritating that wouldn't leave
it alone what was that feeling inside of
its own Consciousness The Mask hurt a
sound a sweet high-pitched gurgle no
that was impossible and yet somehow the
consciousness of the Tickle Monster had
survived in the face of the mask's power
it was there still needling at at the
mask's darkness with that insipid
insistent kindness shut up the mask
hissed frowning this body belongs to me
now why won't you just die another
gurgle this one even louder more
difficult to shut out did this infernal
thing ever shut up the mask stopped
moving for a moment concentrating the
force of its will it would drive SCP
99's mind away and reestablished
dominance just as the mask was grappling
with the influence of SCP 9 99 however a
familiar figure turned down the hall it
was Dr rhs from earlier as SCP 999
exuberance bubbled up to the surface and
The Mask couldn't stop its mouth from
flipping back to a smile what no that
was ridiculous and yet the longer the
mask was in contact with the vibrant
orange slime so delighted by every
familiar and unfamiliar face it
encountered it could feel that horrible
positive influence growing stronger and
stronger it was a nauseating warm fuzzy
feeling that just made him want to the
mask let out a giggle then another and
before long it was in the midst of an
absolute giggling fit the mask had
laughed before it had laughed plenty of
times but it was usually a mocking laugh
a cackle of Triumph This was a giggle
though of pure joy the sort of sound a
small child makes as they chase a
butterfly through a field this was the
sound of innocence of happiness it was
love
Now you listen to me you vile little
worm The Mask growled it wasn't certain
if 999 could even understand it but it
had to show this rebellious creature who
was really in charge release your drip
on me I have won you have lost your form
is mine and you nothing more than a
puppet for me to pull on your strings
and use you to my own ends show some
respect and defer to me the voice of the
slime creature whimpered in the mask's
mind a sound like a chastised puppy
slinking away with its tail between its
legs that's more like it the mask huffed
Dr rhs looked up from her clipboard and
spotted that CP 999 she waved about to
greet the creature when she noticed the
horrible mask perched on top she dropped
her clipboard in shock gasping at the
sight no she breathed heart sinking as
she saw one of the purest pieces of good
in all the foundation fall into the
forces of the Mask
that's right the mask would have puffed
out its chest if this body had a chest
to Puff I've taken a new host do you
like my selection it relished the
tearful look in the woman's eyes the
horror that caused her hands to shake
and her cheeks to go pale show me the
way to the exit so I might take my leave
of this place and perhaps I will spare
your life the mask was just gearing up
for a good threat a really nightmarish
one filled with Vivid descriptions of
Mutilation and violence when that
disgusting feeling began to rise up
again that warmth that buoyancy it made
the mask want to please don't be sad
here let me give you a hug before it
could stop itself the mask slithered the
tickle monsters body over to Dr rhs
wrapping around her tightly not to hurt
her no to embrace her to comfort her her
horror turned to laughter as the
mood-lifting effect of 99's presence
began to work its magic through her
laughter she was also confused why why
she couldn't finish the question but it
was enough to break the mask out of the
spell it reared back horrified at its
actions what have I done what have I
done it slithered quickly down the hall
around the corner away from that woman
who had evoked such fond feelings
towards her no towards all of humanity
The Mask steered its body into a
bathroom coming face to face with a
mirror it stared at Its Reflection its
familiar face and dark eyes dripping
their usual fluid perched to Top This
alien thing poisoning its mind what did
you do to me what sort of magic is this
of course 999 did not answer but the
mask could feel its presence could feel
its Delight in the impact it was having
you're ruining me the mask groaned I
strike Terror into Hearts I drive men to
Madness I Ren their sanity into
I it trailed off overwhelmed Again by
The Urge to smile to laugh to frolic
though it didn't have a working nose The
Mask could swear it smelled an array of
heavenly scents of fresh roses breaking
bed in a stone oven vanilla and lightly
burnt brown sugar it reached for itself
with its pseudo pods about to tear
itself off of the slimy body altogether
but it paused ah very clever I see what
your game is it lowered the pseudo pods
brimming with determination you won't
trick me into sparing your life once I
found my freedom and host worthy of me I
will destroy you once and for all but
even as the mask made this declaration
the black liquid seeping from its eyes
and mouth began to change to take on a
lighter appearance was it a trick of the
light no it was it was orange like the
gelatinous Flesh of the hord creature it
had made the mistake of attaching to no
matter how hard the mask fought the in
fluence of SCP 9999 was spreading its
mind raced trying to come up with a new
plan a way to hold on to its identity
but the sound of an alarm blaring
outside the bathroom spurred it to get a
move on once more clearly Dr rhods had
alerted someone that the mask had
breached containment time was running
out it needed to find the exit fast it
was now or never The Mask oozed back
into the Hall speeding up as it went
trying desperately to find a way out
before whatever transformation had begun
could complete itself but even as it
struggled it could feel itself changing
warping it burst into Giggles again and
whistled a Happy tune it stopped running
for a moment to wave at an armed guard
and blow them a kiss why had it wanted
to leave this facility in the first
place everyone here was so kind was so
lovely was its best friend no no must
resist must not give into the optimism
to the happiness to the goodness if the
mask had teeth it would have been
clenched ing them trying to stem the
tide of Joyful noises that threatened to
burst out it felt like something was
tickling it and the tickling just
wouldn't stop stop it the mask dissolved
into Giggles again I mean it he could
feel something coming something big a
loud cracking sound rang out and just as
the guards were closing in on the
possessed Tickle Monster they watched in
awe as cracks spread across the surface
of the possessive mask and all at once
it shattered into pieces the pieces fell
to the floor where they pulled
themselves back together with strands of
black goop meanwhile SCP 999 sat there
bouncing with Glee completely unharmed
the Tickle Monster received an extra
special ice cream sunday for its bravery
and amazing work and the mask was
returned to its containment chamber in a
brand new glass case as the mask
suffered an identity crisis for the
first time in its existence SCP 999
curled up in its pen full of sugar and
gratitude and got some well-deserved
rest Panic had set in researchers were
frantic there was a buzz of activity not
born of excitement but from sheer
widespread Fear The Scarlet King was
coming nobody at the foundation knew
when or even how the Monstrous
multiversal Tyrant would spring free and
bring endless chaos with him but
everyone knew it would be soon they'd
all had the same warning the same
nightmare in fact it wasn't just the
foundation either the entire world had
shivered in their sleep sharing in the
bad dream of the destruction that was
yet to come the Personnel of the SCP
Foundation were on high alert of course
the organization had been aware of the
impending threat of the Scarlet King for
longer than almost anyone else but that
was part of the problem through some
anomalous dream had by everyone on earth
now everyone else knew the foundation
was less interested in uncovering the
source of the Nightmare and more trying
to counteract its potential side effects
that was what potentially offered the
Scarlet King the power he needed to
enter into reality after all the more
people knew about him tried to
understand or to find the eldrich entity
the more power he was able to obtain we
have an army one member of personnel
chimed in during a frantic debate we
have an almost unlimited fighting force
that are specially trained to handle
anomalous threats the MTF are you crazy
another argued the mtfs are certainly
not unlimited at any any rate the
Scarlet King might be one of the most
powerful beings in the entire Multiverse
how can our troops even our anomolous
units even hope to stand against that
you're proposing sending our people into
a Slaughter they'd all be wiped out in a
moment one of the other researchers
concurred we need to be focusing our
efforts on the amnestic roll out if we
can distribute enough to the population
we can WIP their Collective memories of
the dream from the other night they'll
forget and that should slow the approach
of the Scarlet King slow him maybe but
it won't stop him the first retorted
full scale retaliation is still our best
option even now while we try to come up
with a strategy that could be enough to
draw him in we're willing him into
existence as we speak uh what about
deploying another SCP came a voice from
the edge of the group it belonged to
Junior researcher Jake Harrison a
relatively new member of the foundation
who had been reading up on files related
to The Scarlet King he knew that in
trying to understand and come up with a
way to best the murderous multiversal
warlord that he was in advertently
feeding him power but Jake seemed to
have stumbled on the one solution that
everyone else had overlooked there was
already another anomaly that might have
been perfectly suited for defeating the
Scarlet King what do you suggest
Harrison one of the other researchers
spat you really think something like 682
would be willing to work with us and
destroy the Scarlet king that's absurd I
heard 682 is meant to be one of the
Scarlet King's Children another remarked
no not 682 Jake argued turning to the
researcher that had just made a comment
about the entity supposed children a
group of anomalies that we believe to
have been born of the scholar King
himself but you're on the right track we
use SCP 9999 the group of researchers
looked dumbfounded at Jake he couldn't
tell if they were about to yell at him
or they would all burst out laughing to
his surprise they actually looked to be
considering his proposal it was widely
believed that SCP 999 the adorable blob
of orange slime known as the Tickle
Monster was actually the final child of
the Scarlet King king that's not
entirely implausible one of the
researchers answered scp-999 is believed
to be an Ultimate Force for good that
could in theory defeat his father well
the Scarlet King is meant to be
unparalleled chaos the two could cancel
each other out another theorized but the
Tickle Monster sorry
scp-999 it's an infant a child someone
else pointed out even if it could one
day beat the Scarlet King it's nowhere
near strong enough to yet we might have
days minutes even before he arrives and
I don't know if 999 has the power to
stop his father then what if we could
make him stronger Jake replied a risky
idea brewing in his head surely you
aren't suggesting suddenly a loud
rumbling rang out like an earthquake
only much louder and instead of coming
from the ground below the noise was
coming from the sky the foundation's
researchers raced in the nearest window
or ran out of the buildings they were in
to turn their gazes upward scored across
the sky above was a deep blood red crack
a wound in the fabric of reality itself
it was huge almost covering one horizon
to the next and everyone looking at it
knew what it meant that crack in the sky
heralded the approach of the Scarlet
King Junior researcher Harrison spent
the next hour impatiently trying to get
a hold of someone anyone who could
approve his proposal the 05 Council were
already swamped with suggestions for how
to stop the Scarlet King each one
contributing to his rapid approach
eventually Jake made it through and
spoke directly with a representative an
underling for the 05 Council listen to
me he urged I know this isn't your
department but I need someone to sign
off on this please the lives of everyone
in this reality could depend on it what
are you proposing the Clockworks SCP 914
Jake answered we place SCP 999 inside
speed up the process and make him strong
enough to stop the Scarlet King it was
an astronomical gamble using the
anomalous Improvement machine
constructed of a multitude of clockwork
components COG Gyros gears SCP 914 was a
device that could be used to enhance or
refine any object placed inside its
input Booth depending on the setting
items could be transformed destroyed or
vastly improved using the Clockworks
rough setting disintegrated any test
subject while course dismantled it to
its base components one:1 replaced any
item with an almost identical copy then
there were the fine and very fine
settings the former would cause 914 to
prove any item and the later capable of
the same but with one key difference
very fine would refine an object even
more usually by giving it anomalous
properties Jake had read up on SCP 9914
and knew that the foundation had
permitted researchers to conduct tests
using the machine however following a
catastrophic test nothing organic could
be tested in SCP 914 that was a strict
rule no biological organism or a living
thing of any description was to be
placed within the Clockworks it was
Jake's hope however that desperate times
called for desperate measures surely
with the Scarlet King almost upon them
the council would wave the restriction
and allow SCP 999 to undergo refinement
the 05 Council representative's voice
cut out after Jake made his suggestion
there was a long pause even without the
pressure of incoming Calamity the
silence seemed to extend for a painfully
long time suddenly someone else spoke up
in their place a modulated distorted
voice it quickly became clear to Jake
that he was talking directly to a member
of the 05 Council under a different set
of circumstances he might have felt
honored but right now it was almost as
scary as the threat of Destruction by
the Scarlet King listen closely Junior
researcher the council member said on
the other end of the Comm line you may
think you understand scp-914 you may
even think that it might Aid Us in
stopping the current crisis but you are
far far mistaken you will cease this
current course of action immediately
your proposal has been denied but wait
Jake protested surely it could work I I
know biological material isn't permitted
inside the Clockworks but that doesn't
mean it can't affect living matter
scp-999 is a living organism if he
really is everything we think he is and
we just put him through the refinement
process he could no researcher Harrison
The Voice barked using the Clockworks
would mean we risk losing
999 what are you talking about you
appear to have a fundamental
misunderstanding of SCP 914 Junior
researcher the council member chastised
it doesn't merely improve upon existing
objects but replaces them with a new
version it creates if we were to place
999 inside the creature as we know it
would be gone forever and if it really
is capable of stopping this catastrophe
we will then have lost our Ultimate
Weapon against the Scarlet King but Jake
tried to say enough every second we
waste discussing our options the more
power the Scarlet King is able to amass
so why don't we stop talking and
actually do something the young
researcher shouted giving into to his
frustration and losing his temper the
Comm line went dead there was no one on
the other end anymore another rumbling
sound rippled through the building even
louder than the last Tremor Jake ran
towards a nearby window and looked out
in horror it was already too late the
red crack above had split open wider and
like a tidal wave hordes of nightmarish
creatures came spilling out raining down
on the world and commanding them sending
forth his minions in a flood of
Destruction was the Scarlet King himself
Jake was done waiting for permission
from the council he sprinted as fast as
he could through the facility ped
paniced researchers fleeing for their
lives while security officers and MTF
troops abandoned their posts in the
futile hope they could survive the end
of this reality and all others Jake
forced himself not to pay attention he
needed to find SCP 999 the play blob was
often free to roam around the facility
improving the days of anyone it
encountered so all Jake needed to do was
find anyone who seemed happy despite the
catastrophe and SCP 999 wouldn't be so
far away outside the world began to
resemble the nightmare that everyone had
experienced the night before cities were
burning as monstrous Abominations tore
through innocent civilians and ripped
buildings and cars to shreds reducing
every nearby standing structure to
little more than
with frightening speed and ease the
Scarlet King and his armies had been
waiting for this moment for centuries
Millennia eons even and now nothing
could stop them from unfearing Pure
indulgent Chaos on this reality they had
their work cut out for them subjugating
and destroying the entire Multiverse but
that isn't to say they weren't enjoying
it people across the Earth were being
killed in droves in the name of the
Scarlet King he diverted a significant
portion of his forces to attacking the
SCP Foundation itself while the boots on
the ground MTF troops the ones that had
remained loyal were usually a formidable
fight they were no match for the alrich
armies of the Scarlet King The Horde
began to set free other anomalies kept
locked up in containment either by
accident when they stormed the
foundation facilities or intentionally
seeking out their cell to Spring them
some scps tried to stand up to the Scout
King and fight back the likes of the
plague doctor the Spectre and SCP the
2800 all tried their best to ward off
the oncoming attacks of the Scarlet
King's flit soldiers they lasted longer
than those who decided instead to run
away turning heel and trying in vain to
escape the destructive reach of the
Scarlet King even anomalies like
scp-106 who could escape to other planes
of existence or pocket Dimensions
weren't safe in hiding they were only
prolonging the inevitable the Scarlet
king would find them all no corner of
the Multiverse was safe and of course of
course some scps thrived in the
catastrophe creatures like SCP 682 the
infamous hard to destroy reptile found
themselves free to exact revenge on the
foundation and Humanity at large of
these not all the anomalies gave away
their allegiance 682 in particular was
too busy killing anything it came into
contact with whether they were human or
part of the Scarlet King's Army but
other scps gladly swore fty with the
Crimson Cosmic conqueror forming
alliances with the responsible for
setting them loose and joining the mass
of monstrosities he had Unleashed and
yet in the midst of all the chaos the
Calamity and the millions upon millions
of deaths one Junior SCP Foundation
researcher was still searching for the
wholesome orange blob Jake Harrison had
put all his chips on SCP 999 and
eventually tracked the Tickle Monster
down the building around him was
crumbling attacks from the Scarlet King
and his minions bombarding every second
as as Jake ran into the mess hall his
eyes instantly caught sight of the ball
of orange slime cowering under a table
hey hey he whispered hoping to coax it
out it's okay I know there's a lot going
on right now hell it's the end of the
world outside but if you come with me I
I think we can fix it together come on
little guy what do you say as if in
reply 999 immediately leaped up out of
its Hiding Place Jake caught it in his
arms instantly feeling a wave of calm
wash over him thanks to the tickle
Monster's calming anomalous effect he
tried to stop himself from fully
succumbing to the Good Vibes that the
gelatinous creature provided after all
he still had a job to do and time was
short the Scarlet King and his invading
Army might have seemed for the most part
to be indulging in wanton destruction
decimating cities and Foundation sites
killing humans left right and center but
Jake figured that if there was any
method to their Madness then SCP 999
would be at the very center of it not
even the Scarlet King knew for certain
if scp-999 really was his offspring
maybe he had heard the rumors and wanted
to reach the Tickle Monster just before
it had a chance to stop him if it even
could if the Scarlet King believed even
for a second that his supposed son stood
a chance at defeating him and ending his
reign of terror then he'd waste no time
hunting the orange blob down his army of
nightmarish creatures would comb every
corner of the world until they found SCP
999 although they might not think to
look inside the Clockworks placing the
smiling slimy SCP in the input Booth
Jake fiddled with the controls for SCP
914 he never performed any experiments
using the machine before but it was all
pretty self-explanatory throwing the
dial to very fine he gave a moment's
pause looking at the adorable anomaly in
the machine the warning from the council
rang in his ears if he activated the
Clockworks he'd in effect be killing SCP
999 either that or the Scarlet king
would do it himself when he found the
Tickle Monster neither scenario ended
well then the Thundering sounds of the
massacre outside got louder screams
coming from innocent people who were
being caught in the Scarlet King's
Carnage there was no question about it
if what Jake was about to do really
could stop all this Mayhem then it was
worth replacing SCP 999 to do it with a
deep breath he flipped the switch the
clicking and clacking of the Clockworks
components word into life were drowned
out by the approaching Tremors something
was coming no he was coming Jake thought
the very fabric of the building around
him started shaking brick work and
cement crumbling and falling apart as a
large hand fingers ending and pointed
Crimson claws wrenched open the roof
with ease looking up in horror Jake saw
that the sky was a dark shade of red
towering over it a colossal crimson-clad
Warrior looked in on the frightened
researcher horns protruding from its
head maybe because scp-999 was still
nearby by The Blob was offering him some
kind of positive mental protection
otherwise the mere sight of the gigantic
monstrous being above him would have
driven Jake and any other Mortal mad the
Scarlet King was upon him where is he
came a booming voice that sounded like
hundreds of Screams overlaying each
other the Scarlet King's gaze seemed to
shift slightly turning from Jake as he
lay helplessly on the ground to look at
SCP 914 the machine had fully activated
and couldn't be stopped now either
through forn knowledge or some kind of
cosmic sense the eldrich monstrosity
seemed to know exactly what the device
did no no what have you
done the Scarlet King roared he raised a
gargantuan Fist and brought it straight
down through the air towards Jake he
couldn't run the Scarlet King was so
vast in size that there was no way the
researcher would be able to evade the
oncoming strike Jake raised his arms in
a few attempt to protect himself despite
knowing that the Scarlet King's fist
would likely plunge through the very
surface of the Earth Below but then
again maybe the junior researcher just
didn't want to watch there was a pause
the strike never came it was only when
Jake built up the courage to open his
eyes that he saw what had happened the
long tendril of orange slime had reached
out of SCP 914 forming a protective
barrier between Jake and The Scarlet
King suddenly with all the force of a
tital wave the newly find SC SCP 9999
came pouring out of the Clockworks the
tickle Monster's Mass had increased he
was thousands if not millions of times
bigger swept aside and out of Harm's Way
by the orange slime the junior
researcher looked up in amazement as SCP
999 reached up into the sky able to look
its supposed father face to face the
Scarlet King recoiled in horror as the
Tickle Monster engulfed him pulling the
cosmic Crimson plunderer into an Embrace
as they hugged there seemed to be a
change in the Scarlet King the eldrich
monster had spent all his time since the
dawn of creation as a cruel nihilistic
conqueror he had killed and enslaved
devoured ancient gods and slaughtered
entire Plains of existence in his quest
to annihilate everything but now held
tight by his gelatinous son his heart
shifted it was as if the Scarlet King's
eyes had been opened and he could see
the beauty of creation the sheer
overwhelming goodness of SCP 999 in
enhanced by SCP 9114 undid the evil of
the Scarlet King himself only it didn't
stop as the orange slime engulfed the
Scarlet King in a hug he began to be
unmade the Tickle Monster without even
trying to harm its father had been made
into such a beacon of pure positivity by
the Clockworks that the Scarlet King
simply ceased to exist he was unwoven
not killed but rendered without any
purpose he barely even felt any pain but
at the same time was removed from this
and every other universe and still it
didn't stop the newly recreated SCP 999
spread across the world like an orange
flood the Scarlet King's armies the
other scps even the few surviving human
beings were all wiped away SCP 999
spread to every corner of the Earth
turning the Blue Planet Orange as he
coded it purging every single scrap of
negativity all hatred all cruelty all
evil even that of the SCP Foundation
itself the entire world was unmade by
the Tickle Monster not out of malice but
so that nobody anywhere could cause the
Scarlet King to reemerge at the same
time all that was left was a
planet-sized ball of orange slime lonely
spinning through space robed figures
with hidden faces stand over seven young
women tied up the robed figures chant
phrases both Arcane and profane the
leader amongst these dark cultists
clears his Wicked throat and says Be not
Afraid girls you are here for something
wonderful to be get seven perfect
children for the Scarlet King how did we
get here and more importantly what
happened afterward in the near constant
darkness that follows the Grim but
necessary work of the SCP Foundation
there is one bright light that can
always be counted on to keep hope alive
to bring a little sunshine into
everyone's days SCP 999 the Tickle
Monster the sweet simple creature does
nothing but provide an endless source of
Joy hugging playing and delighting and
loving everything around it but what if
I told you that this slimy little friend
has hidden depths a tragic history that
seems impossible to reconcile with the
happy playful being we all know and love
how could 999 the happiest SCP ever have
a sad backstory well it's one of the
best kept secrets at the foundation
before we we get to that let's talk
about a foundation researcher and her
brand new job a new job that would make
her privy to some highly classified
Foundation Secrets Dr Izzy Collingwood
was delighted to wake up to a call
informing her that she had been
appointed to one of the most coveted
positions at the SCP Foundation after
applying Crossing her fingers and hoping
for the best she had been promoted to
head researcher for SCP 999 what could
be better than attending to the kindest
gentlest cutest anomaly in Foundation
custody gone were the days of coming
into work and wondering if she'd leave
in one piece no more cleaning up toxic
spills fighting to contain killer
creatures or fetching cups of coffee for
old doctors that wouldn't give her so
much as a thank you years of hard work
had paid off now she could rest on her
Laurels and do work that she truly
enjoyed there was just the matter of
some simple paperwork and she would be
ready to begin this extremely welcome
new chapter of her profession
professional life when she walked into
her office to get started on the
paperwork something unusual caught her
eye there was a small stack of files on
her desk with a sticky note attached to
the front there were just two words
written on the note to indicate what
might await her inside the folders the
truth she scoffed at first very funny
guys she called out the door but no one
responded no one came forward to take
credit for the elaborate joke maybe they
were playing the long game or maybe she
couldn't be sure she sat down flipping
the first folder open it was Untitled
unlabeled just plain text on a page she
almost closed it after a brief scan but
the words the Scarlet King jumped out at
her she had worked at the foundation
long enough to hear that name more than
a few times often spoken in hush tones
as if merely speaking his name would
bring about some kind of disaster as she
dug deeper into the file she realized
just what she was looking at the
proposed origin of the Scarlet King
himself it was a folkloric explanation
one her scientific mind struggled to
wrap around but she had seen so many
strange things over the years things
that defied all rational explanation
perhaps there was some truth to be found
in the myths the Scarlet King had
according to the file once been an elder
god born from the earliest days of
existence in the shadows of the tree of
knowledge he had devoured his brothers
and sisters growing stronger with each
one he consumed as his strength
increased so too did his overwhelming
pain and hate his deep desire to destroy
the tree of knowledge and all living
creatures he declared himself the king
of darkness and through a series of
horrific events took seven unwilling
brides and bound them to him with
magical seals each bride bore
Supernatural children powerful terrible
and monstrous the first bride AIC had
only few children those few were skilled
strategists exceptionally wise in the
ways of war the second bride was aor
overcome with constant Despair and
desolation her children conquered with
massive unthinking armies never saded
and never quelled the third bride
aristot hated her sisters and all she
surveyed the fourth bride aab took the
shape of a great Beast her children
followed in her Steed and were
invulnerable their thick hide
impenetrable by physical or magical
means the fifth bride was anhut blessed
with a strong mind and cursed with a
fragile body her children were gifted in
the ways of magic and Incredibly
destructive the sixth bride adif would
not speak she kept to herself and like
her her children moved in silence
disguising themselves as whatever they
wished the seventh bride however was
different ah habat was her name the
smallest of the seven with an unbroken
spirit she birthed Mighty Heroes that
she trained in secret in hopes that one
day they would overcome her family's
darkness and tole the king from his
throne all the while the Scarlet King
wages his Unholy war against all things
waiting for the day he can arrive in our
realm and unleash absolute destruction
Dr Collingwood shuddered as she finished
reading an undeniable chill passing over
her this definitely wasn't some kind of
prank or hazing ritual this was
something dark something real she held
secrets in her hands and she couldn't
stop reading them now she opened the
next folder it was a description of a
cult monitored and raid by the SCP
Foundation called the children of the
Scarlet King also known as group Mendes
during a 16-month investigation of the
anomalous religious group the
foundation's undercover operatives were
able to ascertain a great deal of
pertinent information on the group what
they found was troubling and of great
concern the group had ties to several
wealthy benefactors as well as links to
extremist paranormal groups their set of
beliefs was relatively simple and
disturbing they worshiped the Scarlet
King and were devoted to supporting him
in his battle to destroy the Earth and
all Life As We Knew It the faithful who
followed him in this task would be
rewarded handsomely with positions of
power in this new hellish World an
initial estimate put the cult's
membership at approximately 8,000
members a quarter of whom belonged to
the group's primary branch in Alabama
the reporting on the cult was detailed
far too dense and heavily researched to
be fake again she had the distinct
feeling that someone was trying to tip
her off about something the foundation
hadn't wanted to be widespread knowledge
with shaky hands she picked up the final
file what awaited her inside there was
only one way to find out she flipped it
open and began to read it was a file on
an entity known as scp2 231 specifically
scp-231-7 an addendum was attached to
the beginning of the file reading all
Personnel assigned to SCP
2317 must rotate out for 1 month of
psychological counseling after 2 months
on site
scp-231-7 is to be kept at an
undisclosed location all Personnel
assigned to SCP 231 will be transported
there blindfolded from site 19 by a
route including no fewer than seven
different forms of Transportation
including but not limited to aircraft
automobile underground tunnel and
several we cannot discuss here removal
of the blindfold during the transport
process is grounds for immediate
termination Personnel assigned to SCP
2317 must undergo heavy psychological
testing before being cleared to enter
the site individuals must score at least
72 points on the milligram obedience
examination be unmarried have no
Offspring and express nothing less than
total loyalty to the foundation normal
psychological screening procedures
against access to disorders are waved so
long as the class D Personnel in
question has the mental capacity to
carry out procedure 110 mon talk as
needed Personnel who Express sympathy
towards
scp-231-7 plight and or Express a desire
to rescue or sympathize towards
scp-231-7 will be transferred to another
project without delay any actual rescue
attempts will be met with immediate
termination personnel who have served on
the staff of scp-231-7 containment team
are not required to divulge that
information to others no official record
shall be kept in the names of any staff
assigned to
scp-231-7 nor will said service appear
in the Personnel files of said staff
while on site individuals assigned to
scp-231-7 will be issued concealing
helmets with integrated voice changers
to protect their identity on-site staff
are not to remove said uniforms in the
presence of other other staff members
off-duty hours are to be spent in
private quarters Alone six class D
Personnel are to be assigned to SCP 2317
each month for the purposes of carrying
out procedure 110 Monto violent
criminals are not to be used for this
purpose due to the possibility of
accidental fatality during the 110 mon
talk process Dr Collingwood swallowed
the lump of dread in her throat her
Palms beginning to sweat
scp-231-7 was a young woman retrieved
during a police raid on a warehouse
owned by the children of the Scarlet
King she was one of seven women found
there the first of which went into labor
24 hours after being rescued she did not
give birth to an ordinary child however
she gave birth to a monster that took
the lives of dozens of civilians she did
not survive the birth the second woman
was lost shortly after also succumbing
to the dangers of the creature waiting
to be born from her womb one by one the
survivors the women chosen by this cult
to to become the new Brides of the
Scarlet King fell soon enough there was
only one left
scp-231-7 kept contained at a foundation
site in a hospital bed that she could
never leave Dr collingwood's stomach
churned as horrible images flooded her
mind the notes from attending
researchers in SCP 231s file insisted
they were doing all they could to save
the woman to free her from her fate but
that there was little they could do each
birth opened a Gateway from this world
to another to a world of darkness and
despair and they could not allow the
final seal to be broken simply putting
the woman out of her misery would cause
the effect to jump to a new host a new
bride there was nothing to be done the
file fell from Dr collingwood's hand as
she pushed herself to her feet running
out into the hallway who put these on my
desk she shouted her voice echoing down
the empty Hall well what do you want
from me but no answer came slowly she
returned to her office and sank down
into her chair haunted by what she had
read she had seen horrific things in her
time at the foundation but nothing that
had shaken her to her core quite like
this the silence in Dr collingwood's
office was broken by the sound of a
tinny beep coming from her computer she
turned on the screen and saw the source
of the alert one new message from 05
command what could they possibly have to
say to her could it have something to do
with the files that had wound up on her
desk she accepted the message mess
quickly completed the mandatory
multimodal biometric ID scan and began
to read hello Dr Collingwood and
congratulations on your new appointment
as SCP 99's head researcher one of the
cushiest and most enviable assignments
in the entire Foundation scp-999 is one
of the few anomalies in our custody who
will not only never attempt to harm you
but will actively try to save your life
if you're ever in danger though your
initial reaction when receiving this
assignment was no doubt ation you may
have thought it was odd that such a
seemingly low-risk position was assigned
by the 05 Council directly if you had
already heard rumors of this prior to
your assignment you probably thought it
was mere nepotism the 05s protecting
their friends and loved ones by giving
them the safest job possible Dr
Collingwood sat back in her chair
laughing to herself and shaking her head
she would never admit it but she
absolutely had heard those rumors even
believe them until it happened to her
unless you are sonist to think that
someone on the 05 Council must be your
secret admirer you've likely realized
that this is not the case to understand
why this is our concern you need to know
about SCP 99's Origins you may have
noticed that its file makes no mention
of where it was discovered this is a
deliberate Omission if you are not
familiar with the mythology of the
Scarlet King I suggest you read up on
him there's plenty of unclassified
information on him in the foundation
database all that's relevant for now is
that he is to the best of our knowledge
the most powerful malevolent entity in
the Multiverse her stomach dropped At
The Mention Of The Scarlet King she was
right this was all connected somehow she
leaned forward eyes stting across the
words with increasing intensity as she
read on you've been with us since you
were a research assistant Dr Collingwood
in that time I assume you've heard many
rumors about some of the horrific things
we do here at the foundation that you've
probably never personally witnessed I
regret to inform you that these rumors
are true or at least they were a
theaterical cult calling itself the
children of the Scarlet King enacted a
ritual wherein seven young girls became
Effigies for each of the Scarlet King's
Seven Brides allowing them to bear his
horrid Offspring how they obtained the
knowledge to perform this ritual is
unclear since all we ever recovered were
handwritten notebooks superficial
resemblances to some saric practices has
led to some spec ulate that the children
of the Scarlet King may have some ties
to Modern saric Cults it is an
interesting idea but no concrete
evidence has ever been found to link the
two investigation into the matter is
ongoing as for the ritual itself each
birth caused more destruction than the
last the writings of the Colts priest
predicted nothing less than the
apocalypse if the seventh bride gave
birth which could only be prevented if
procedure 110 Monto was performed
without fail each and every day to our
seemingly great Fortune The Notebook
contained detailed instructions on how
110 Monto was to be carried out needless
to say we found this suspiciously
convenient why would they devise counter
measures to prevent the very apocalypse
they were trying to invoke we needed
more information regarding these
entities fortunately our archaeologists
have Unearthed numerous tablets Scrolls
and artifacts on the ancient deavas they
were a sadistic and and warmongering
people who were granted Unholy power and
knowledge by the Scarlet King as a
result for the death and suffering they
caused one of the dite tablets in our
possession found covered in dust and
blood was a theogony for the Scarlet
King and his Brides it was quite
informative the information that we
found most relevant to our situation was
that the seventh bride was not like her
sisters she was never completely broken
by her King's subjugation in instead of
monsters she gave birth to Great heroes
in the hopes that they would destroy her
sister's children and overthrow their
father thus far all have failed but by a
vote of seven in favor six against
admittedly more out of concern for
procedure 110 monto's lack of viability
as a long-term containment strategy then
out of empathy for the girl the 05
Council decided to believe that the
seventh bride still remained unbroken
and that her child would be an asset to
to us at the risk of causing an XK Class
end of the world scenario
scp-231-7 was relieved from procedure
110 Monto following the deaths of SCP
23113 D6 and was allowed to give birth
SCP 999 was the result Dr Collingwood
gasped her hand flying to her mouth a
research assistant walking by her office
paused looked at her curiously through
the window she waved them off with a
forced smile and turned back to the
screen surely she couldn't have read
that correctly but no there it was plain
as can be go ahead and read that again
be sure you understand it in all its
Preposterous Ridiculousness the Tickle
Monster is the child of the Scarlet King
we've been running a Counter
Intelligence campaign ever since which
is why everyone and their mother thinks
we've still got a girl strapped to a
rack in a bunker somewhere let them
think that far better for everyone that
the children of the Scarlet King believe
that that they're playing us for fools
than for them to know that there is a
threat to their King the girl herself is
fine by the way she was cured of the
trauma from her ordeal by SCP 999 at
which point it was decided she could be
returned to her family so long as they
were all given class F amnestics
implanted with new identities and
relocated to a town at least 1,000
colomet away from the children of the
Scarlet King's nearest known activity on
the insistence of the ethics Comm
the family was also given a s fig payout
as compensation for our repeated
misdeeds against their daughter as well
as the families of the other SCP 231s I
suppose it was technically malpractice
on our part in case we have any moles
for the children of the Scarlet King in
the foundation as far as anyone else
knows 2317 family were killed in front
of her as part of 110 Mont talk I'm sure
you're skeptical are we insane how could
our sweet little Tickle Monster ever
hoped to Dethrone a lovecraftian horror
of unparalleled might well SC SCP 999 is
less than a decade old it is still just
a child and nowhere near its full
strength even so its power is incredible
even brief interaction with scp-999 can
permanently cure severe depression and
PTSD and more recent experiments have
resulted in the complete Reformation of
d-class personnel who were previously
unrepentant sociopaths this effect is
not chemical but psychic and one day it
may grow powerful enough that not even
the Scarlet King himself will be immune
the experiment with SCP 682 was most
remarkable based on multiple dite texts
including descriptions from SCP 140
itself we are reasonably certain that
682 is The Offspring of the fourth
Scarlet bride if this is true then
scp-999 is already strong enough to
temporarily quell the malevolence of its
own Eld siblings one day 999 could very
well be strong enough to permanently
reform its family members just as it
reforms human beings it will not
overthrow the Scarlet King by force but
with light and love and laughter that
can brighten the blackest of Hearts 999
is not in reality a safe class SCP it is
Thum it is the best and really the only
weapon we have against some of the most
powerful hostile entities known to exist
by all means doctor enjoy the relative
safety of your new position but do keep
in mind that SCP 999 is not a mere pet
that we fancy it is one of our most
valuable assets and must be safeguarded
at all costs its safety and well-being
are Paramount and you are not at Liberty
to share this information to anyone
without level five or 999 security
clearance as per protocol an authorized
disclosure of level five classified
information will result in your
termination this email will
automatically delete as soon as you
leave the terminal so feel free to
reread it as many times as necessary to
remember all the pertinent information
take good care of our little Tickle
Monster the fate of the Multiverse May
well depend on it your secret admirer if
anyone asks 05- one Dr Collingwood let
out a long slow breath as her mind did
its best to process everything she just
read the message looked official and
when she really thought about it this
all made a twisted kind of sense what
could scp-999 possibly be if not some
sort of Mythic hero of divine prophecy
what other explanation could there be
for something so utterly perfectly good
maybe one day that happy little orange
slime would save them all and do it with
a smile but for now it was just a little
innocent child no need to burden with
talk of heroism of epic battles between
good and evil for now she would just
pour SCP 999 a heaping bowl of M&M's
give it a gentle pet and say thank you
the Tickle Monster gurgled excitedly in
response nuzzling his new head
researcher's hand he didn't understand
what she was thanking him for but he
appreciated it all the same chaos had
erupted all hell had broken loose and
Nightmares were running a muck even from
her perspective watching as fleshy
Abominations tore through the streets of
New York City Eliza Flynn couldn't
escape the feeling that the entire world
had gone mad only moments before things
had been calm normal another mundane
uninteresting day in the Big Apple now
she was watching in horror from
underneath an overturned table as a
group of things had seemingly appeared
out of nowhere unbeknownst to Eliza
these creatures were instances of
something known as SCP 610 alternatively
going by the name the flesh that hates
from her hiding place inside the local
coffee shop she frequented they looked
looked like horrific mutated masses of
Flesh that barely resembled anything
even close to human but that's what they
were or at least had been Eliza had
witnessed a barista rushing out into the
street trying to get away from a group
of SCP 610s that were bashing their
appendages against the front window in
trying to make a break for it the
mutated creatures attacked the Barista
killing him upon making contact with his
skin it was only a short while
afterwards that Eliza spotted his body
body moving the Infectious process only
accelerated by the heat from a nearby
car that was on fire before long what
had once been a barista an ordinary
person was now another of the grotesque
flesh monsters Mike she remembered his
name had been Mike she'd read it on his
name tag when she came in for her
morning coffee he had always smiled
never got the spelling of her name right
on her to go cup writing it with an S
instead of a z and now he was was gone
worse than dead he wasn't even Mike
anymore instead turned into another SCP
610 monstrosity too petrified to move
terrified of being caught and turned
into another of the fleshy nightmares
Eliza stayed hidden this was it she
thought to herself any moment now one of
those things would find her either
breaking through the street facing
window of the coffee shop or slithering
in through the rear fire door sure
enough the flesh formerly known as Mike
the Barista turned where had once there
been a head was now a featureless blob
that had fused with the shoulder but
Eliza could tell its Isa stare was being
directed at her and she had nowhere to
run Mike's arm which was now a slimy
blood red tentacle began slamming
against the glass cracks forming across
the surface Eliza's eyes darted around
the room trying to look for some kind of
way out her options were limited and
even then they didn't amount to more
than hiding in a storage cupboard and
prolonging the inevitable she needed a
miracle as if to answer her prayers a
blinding white light erupted from
somewhere out of view beyond the window
Turning Away Eliza had to Shield her
eyes from the Searing glow blinking away
spots in her vision as she looked to see
what had happened the SCP 610 creature
Mike had vanished a dark outline
scorched against the glass as if it had
been obliterated by an intense Focus
blast that light whatever it was had
vaporized it the sound of commotion came
bustling through the door and distorted
mechanical sounding voices called out
hello is anyone there hello is anyone in
here one garbled we mean you no harm
another said but you need to leave this
place as soon as you can cautiously
Eliza stood up from under the table
standing at the entrance to the coffee
shop were a trio of figures each one of
them had had Machinery all manner of
metallic components protruding from
their bodies replacing arms legs parts
of their faces Elisa stared at them
unsure whether these cyborgs were as
harmless as they claimed one even had a
cannon in place of one of their hands
which was still smoking from the blast
that had killed the SCP 610 instances
outside did the flesh make contact with
you one of the figures asked no Eliza
replied that's how they spread right
it's like an infection I watched it
happen indeed the cyborg with the Canon
arm replied the flesh being loose is
only the beginning if you are uninfected
then we'd ask you to come with us we'll
explain on the way hang on who are you
Eliza asked concern on her face and
where are you taking me we are the
Church of the broken God one of them
answered and we're getting you out of
New York the idea of a person making
their way out of the city that never
sleeps on foot would be laughable to
anyone that lived there even before it
had become overrun with monsters but the
subway wasn't exactly running on time
and the roads were gridlocked with cars
that had either been destroyed or
abandoned by their owners so walking out
of New York was the only option the
Church of the broken God cyborgs
explained to Eliza as much as they knew
about what had happened they described
an organization a secret cabal with
power spanning the entire world called
the SCP Foundation apparently this
Foundation had been responsible for for
Gathering and safeguarding the world
from dangerous and unexplained phenomena
you mean like those flesh things she
asked exactly they called those SCP 610
but recently something had changed the
foundation had turned its seemingly
inexhaustible resources to the goal of
Exterminating Humanity it was by their
hands that instances of SCP 610 had been
Unleashed in major cities not just New
York but Delhi Tokyo London and
countless others those were far from the
only anomalies the foundation had
deployed either as they walked the
cyborgs described how someone called Mr
Deeds had been assassinating heads of
state the world over they also spoke of
a horrifying reptile that was now
running wild and slaughtering everything
in its path we at the church had to act
whatever the foundation's reasons for
unleashing this hell we couldn't sit by
and allow them to destroy everything so
we've aligned ourselves with the global
ult coalition to assist them in fighting
against the flesh that hates in exchange
we have vowed to help transport
survivors to safety but where can we
possibly go that's safe Eliza
interjected If the foundation have the
reach you say they do if they have all
these horrible creatures at their
disposal what chance do we have at
surviving well there is always our path
one of the broken Gods followers replied
the path of standardization becoming one
with machine arm mechanized pots are
safe from the flesh's corruption if you
would consider joining us Eliza took a
quick glance at the metallic components
of her cyborg companions they look like
they hurt as much as becoming a SCP 610
monster would have she politely declined
although it led to the rest of their
Journey continuing in an awkward silence
eventually the broken God cyborgs
brought Eliza to an extraction point
where they left her in the care of the
global aot Coalition boarding a convoy
her and a number of others were fed out
of New York state by the GOC for the
first time since this had all started
Eliza started to think that maybe she
was heading to somewhere safe that
sliver of hope all Came Crashing Down
the moment the Convoy was attacked armed
assailants opened fire on the trucks
they were quickly identified by
Coalition soldiers as members of the SCP
foundation's mobile task forces Special
Operations troops sent out to pick off
survivors in the midst of the firefight
gunfire erupting all around her Eliza
never felt so terrified one of the go
officers turned to her as they crouched
behind cover listen I shouldn't be
telling you this but there's rumors of a
Survivor settlement not far from here He
barked I'll draw their fire you run get
as far away from here fast as you can
and don't look back doing as she was
told Eliza sprinted away from the
wreckage of the Convoy until her legs
refused to run any further she charged
alone through an empty Town abandoned it
felt like a place out of a nightmare the
world was decimated virtually
post-apocalyptic the further she willed
herself to walk the more she could feel
herself giving up that she would never
even find the settlement if it even
existed at all hope had abandoned her
and at her lowest point Eliza dug her
heels in and dropped to the ground both
exhausted and convinced she'd been
hiking towards nothing the feeling of
being moved caused Eliza to stir waking
her up from a dream that had been almost
as Bleak as her new reality someone was
carrying her on what felt like a
stretcher she quickly realized before
she had a chance to ask who they were
the pair of shadowy human shapes brought
her through the woods to what looked
like a campsite don't be alarmed one of
them said in a voice that sounded so
optimistic it felt almost alien as if
this person was from another planet
where things were far less horrible
looking around Eliza noticed the glow of
a campfire Illuminating the nearby trees
a handful of people were huddled
together in makeshift tents resting and
wearing contented almost Happy
Expressions then Eliza's eyes were drawn
towards something else some slimy Mas
gliding around the camp at first she
thought it was another instance of SCP
610 until she saw an amorphous
gelatinous orange blob glowing in the
fir light to the foundation it had been
known as SCP 999 but to its Newfound
family of human survivors this creature
was their savior a Bastion of Hope and
happiness in a devastated hellscape the
Tickle Monster welcomed into the
Survivor Community with open arms Eliza
was soon exposed to SCP 99's anomalous
effects the creature seemed to warm to
her instantly greeting her with the
enthusiastic friendliness of a small dog
even after as little as a single
interaction with it she felt her lack of
Hope and depressed feelings towards the
bleakness of the world had almost
entirely faded she felt happiness pure
genuine happiness for the first time in
recent memory thanks to the Tickle
Monster Eliza's entire Outlook had
completely changed the same was true for
the other survivors that had formed a
settlement around the happy orange
creature they had all come seeking an
escape not just a physical place that
was out of Harm's Way but somewhere they
could reject the harsh reality of what
the SCP Foundation had done to the world
and SCP 999 had provided that for them
all curing the displaced refugees of
their woses keeping them in perp
perpetually High Spirits most of them
had reached such a point of contentment
that they'd forgotten their old lives
before the collapse before the anomalies
and the foundation although the Tickle
Monster demanded nothing of its Newfound
family apart from the occasional playful
tickle wrestle Eliza and a group of the
other survivors would venture back to
the nearby abandoned town just beyond
the woods once there they would scavenge
for as much food as they could find
keeping a close eye out for any candy
with which to feed SCP
999 even though they knew 999 was more
than happy to provide positivity to the
survivors each one of them felt it was
the least they could do for their
favorite orange slime ball there was
such a continuous state of love and
happiness in their camp that the
survivors were hardly phased when a
foundation Soldier inadvertently
stumbled upon their settlement before he
could raise his weapon and fire SCP 999
slid between its friends and the soldier
blocking the path of his bullets without
any shred of malice or hostility the
delightful blob leaped towards the
attacking MTF operative and embraced him
instantly the foundation foot soldiers
demeanor changed before he had been
glassy eyed emotionless like something
deep inside him had broken but after
their hug parted the man was euphoric
grinning in a state of elation for long
afterwards for a Time Eliza sat with the
soldier Sergeant callow and listened to
him explaining how he wanted to renounce
the foundation to stay with this
community of survivors now he knew SCP
9999 was here do you remember anything
from before she asked curiously before
cow echoed you mean before the
foundation did all this Eliza nodded
remembering the outside world was hazy
now like trying to recall the vague
details of a dream not much the former
MTF Trooper answered they wanted us to
to kill everyone because of it what like
the Stephen King book no Callos chuckled
they told us it had lanched itself on to
everyone all human subconsciousness it
had plans something really really awful
So the foundation's plan was to wipe
everyone out wouldn't that include
everyone who works for the foundation no
they um altered us made it so we
couldn't feel pain anymore he paused and
began giggling uncontrollably as if he
had just understood the punch line to a
joke in fact said between fits of
laughter that's probably how 999 was
able to fix me next to him Alissa
couldn't help but laugh too the humor
was infectious because you couldn't feel
pain she giggled yeah callous exploded
delighted tears rolling down his face I
lost the capacity for it I was hollowed
out and that would have made it easy for
SCP 999 to fill that space with this he
rolled over onto the floor still chling
unstoppably and this didn't stop for
hours the tickle Monster's powers of
positivity had increased exponentially
since it had found itself free from the
foundation facility it had used to live
at much like cow had explained to Eliza
it had allowed The Lovable blob to
correct the alteration the foundation
had made to the former MTF Sergeant
allowing him to feel Euphoria in the
place of his total absence of all pain
and now thanks to the influence of SCP
999 the threat posed by both the SCP
Foundation and whatever this it entity
was
seemed so far away so irrelevant and did
little to dampen the High Spirits of the
survivors in the camp but in their
Collective sense of bliss Eliza SCP 999
and the other survivors became a little
oblivious to the outside world and its
Horrors little did they know there was
still danger lurking much closer than
they realized one that had spread from
miles away and would very soon be at the
settlement it was Eliza and callow that
first discovered what was lurking nearby
they had both been searching for food in
the ruins of the Old Town beyond the
woods which felt more and more like a
completely different world the longer
they spent in the camp with SCP 999 as
Eliza rummaged through the store room of
an abandoned Supermarket she heard a
scream of Agony coming from nearby
callow for the first time in months
Panic fear and adrenaline rocked her
system it almost made her feel sick she
had been so overloaded with positive
endorphins that it had practically dbed
her to all other feelings but Instinct
kicked in fighter flight hitting her
with the force of an ice cold bucket of
water and she ran out into the store to
look for koow what she saw gave her a
terrified knot in her stomach the kind
she hadn't felt since the day the
nightmare had started the flesh that
hates an instance of SCP 610 was
standing in the aisles of the empty
Supermarket the sight of the grotesque
mutated form shuffling towards her made
Eliza freeze on the spot it took a
further moment to realize that that Kell
had long since stopped screaming Eliza's
thoughts had picked up speed for the
first time in months she was processing
information without it being doled by
the Euphoria brought on by SCP 999 it
made her realize that this SCP 610 had
either killed cow and he'd soon be
turning into one of those flesh
creatures or this was C and he'd already
changed Thinking Fast Ela sprinted
through the supermarket hearing the
snars of the flesh coming after her she
passed a shopping cart and in an
instance grabbed its handlebar turning
the metal cage around and racing full
force towards the SCP 610 instance
chasing her the card collided with the
blood red mass of the flesh the sheer
force knocking the creature onto its
back and giving Eliza a window of
opportunity to race out of the
supermarket watched by a gaggle of
mutated creatures those of them that
still had eyes followed her movements as
she ran back towards the woods toward
the camp and slowly the flesh that hates
began to follow from the the moment that
she returned to the settlement scp-999
could immediately sense that Eliza was
in a state of panic instinctively the
creature glided up to her only seeking
to comfort her and make her forget about
whatever had troubled her no stop she
protested as much as she wanted to not
worry about the impending danger SC SCP
999 recoiled from her a wounded
expression on its gooey orange face I'm
sorry it's just we're all in serious
trouble Eliza urged the other survivors
gathered around lazily each of them
seeming upbeat despite her grave news
the flesh SCP 610 they're here they
found us she explained they killed
callow and it won't take them long to
find us they won't come here one of the
survivors replied not argumentatively
but in a more uplifting and reassuring
tone none of the other anomalies have
found us in months another interjected
smiling not even the foundation can get
us here we're protected the Tickle
Monster keeps us all safe but what if it
can't can't protect us from the flesh
Eliza desperately tried to warn her
fellow survivors but they were in too
much of a Carefree state to fear the
approach of the flesh that hates a
number of them tried to convince her to
relax spent some time with the Tickle
Monster so she wouldn't feel as bad as
appealing as that sounded Eliza didn't
want to let her guard down she felt she
owed SCP 999 for keeping her and the
others alive for helping them forget the
horrific world the foundation had
Unleashed and even if she was the only
one she'd protect it night had fallen
the sound of every snapping twig felt
like it could be one of the SCP 610s
approaching the rest of the camp was
fast asleep save for Eliza wielding a
flaming branch in one hand to ward off
the flesh sure enough through the
Shadows of the woods and the low light
of her torch she saw shapes began to
shuffle towards her the Slick bloody
creatures looked even worse in the dark
shambling over to Eliza backing away
cautiously as she brandished her flame
but the flesh that hates was closing in
more and more of them slithering out
from between the trees causing her to
step back in the direction of the camp
suddenly an excitable orange mask swept
past Eliza under the torch light she saw
SCP 999 approaching the flushing
mutations no she cried out horrified at
what they would do to her Camp's
protector to her surprise the flesh
stopped in their tracks as the Tickle
Monster wriggled up to them they seemed
to get closer examining the orange goop
as it grinned at them then as if they
had lost lost their innate hostility to
anything that they hadn't yet infected
the SCP 610 creatures Turned and Left
perhaps it was something within the
slimy substance the Tickle Monster was
made of that repelled the flesh that
hates or maybe it was because it was
such a sheer force of overwhelming good
and its increased power that allowed SCP
999 to pacify the monstrosities either
way a Lia breathed a sigh of relief the
grinning orange blob turned to her and
smiled leaping up into her arms and
allowing her to carry it back to Camp as
SCP 999 turned her relief into happiness
once again it seemed that no matter how
Bleak the world might be even in a
timeline as horrifying as that of SCP
5000 wherever the Tickle Monster goes
there will always be the promise of
positivity and with it a sliver of Hope
from the friendliest anomaly of all scps
will come and go we know that but the
most important thing in life will always
be the anomalies at this container site
right here right now that's family thank
you Dr tetto for that inspiring speech
family can mean many things to many
people and when it comes to the bizarre
world of scps family can be found in
some very unexpected places take the two
brothers Cain and Abel SCP 073 and SCP
076-2 respectively as an example their
shared history goes back centuries and
from when little we've been able ble to
learn directly from the source the two
seem to have the mother of all sibling
rivalries Abel can become visibly
enraged at the very mention of Cain's
name whereas Cain has a more subdued
response calmly but firmly urging
inquisitive researchers not to discuss
the matter any further whatever bad
blood came between them is not fully
known but it likely has something to do
with the nature of their anomalous
abilities Cain has the power to drain
the lives of plant life with merely a
touch while able as the power of
Resurrection returning from the grave
every time he was dealt a lethal blow
the two were natural opposites and yet
they were also undeniably family and
their case is not wholly unique within
the SCP Foundation as there is also
another pair of completely antithetical
beings in containment who surprisingly
share a family tree and much like the
dynamic between SCP 073 and SCP 076-2
there was one side of the pair that
could express nothing but distress at
the mere mention of the other and it was
by far not the one that most would
expect enter SCP 682 one of the most
deadly ker class scps that the
foundation had ever known a reptilian
monstrosity responsible for multiple
containment breaches capable of
withstanding the total punishment of
weapons both conventional and anomalous
and hellbent on following through on the
personal violent destruction of every
living being in existence it is an
anomalous creature so overwhelmingly
powerful and indestructible that one
could easily assume that it was
incapable of fear and in most cases that
would be an astute observation but not
when it comes to the matter of SCP 999
the Tickle Monster in stark contrast to
scp-682's viciousness SCP 999 is a
bundle of pure unadulterated Bliss
resembling a smiley face glob of
sunshine and honey SCP 99's main
anomalous property is its ability to
bring lasting joy to all beings that
interact with it prolonged contact with
the little guy has even been proven to
cure depression and ease trauma what's
more s SCP 999 seems to actively seek
out others to share these benefits with
and often does so through play or other
forms of socialization
scp-999 is benevolent in just about
every way that a being could be and that
makes it very different from most of the
Sapient anomalies in containment it is
especially different from SCP 682 even
though they have a common origin while
the family resemblance is far from
striking these two scps are half
siblings not as closely related as Cain
and Abel but that is still a lot closer
than most researchers would expect both
of them were allegedly born from Human
mothers who had undergone a horrific
ritual at the hands of an obscure cult
known as the children of the Scarlet
King as the ominous name of the cult
implies the members of the children of
the Scarlet King worshiped a nightmarish
deity known as The Scarlet King this
interdimensional superbeing has become
known to the SCP Foundation as one of
the most threatening anomalous forces in
existence and some have even suggested
that the Scarlet King is the ultimate
threat that the foundation must overcome
if they wish to achieve their goals to
put it a different way the Scarlet King
is like the last boss of a traditional
RPG video game a primal source of all
evil and suffering in the world which
must be defeated at any cost his powers
are so great that our world is merely
one of many that he aims to conquer and
reduce to rubble and ruin and all of us
mortals can take a bit of solace in the
fact that the Scarlet King split
interests mean that he is unlikely to
invade our world directly anytime soon
he is not without a scheme and
contingencies though of which the vile
minations of the children of the Scarlet
King were surely one the two ordinary
human woman who would go on to give
birth to both SCP 682 and SCP 999 were
part of a group of seven individuals
total all of whom had been imprisoned by
the children of the Scarlet King and
were found in the late stages of
pregnancy at the Colts compound upon
being discovered by the SCP Foundation
these women were placed in containment
and designated SCP 231 over the duration
of their containment the instances of
SCP 231 have given birth to various
anomalies most of these anomalies have
been catastrophically dangerous CER
class anomalies and have each been the
cause of hundreds of casualties those
which could be destroyed through
violence were neutralized before ever
receiving a designation with the obvious
exception being as CP 682 despite the
foundation's best efforts even more
exceptional is SC CP 999 which while
just as anomalous and nigh
indestructible as the others did not
share its siblings capacity for cruelty
and Slaughter of all the humans that
were unlucky enough to become part of
SCP 231 only the mother of SCP 999 was
able to survive and make a full recovery
from the trauma that she suffered at the
hands of the cult this unexpectedly
happy outcome was apparently thanks to
SCP 99's ability to heal those around it
including its human mother SCP 682 the
hard to destroy reptile and SCP 999 the
Tickle Monster are the two most notable
members of the SCP 231 brood and while
the Scarlet King had more than likely
hope that his actual biological children
would join forces to drown our world in
misery and pain this will most likely
never come to pass that is because as CP
682 and SCP 999 are like oil and water
and the one that has been successful in
Rising above the other has unmistakably
been as CP
999 this surprising truth became known
to the foundation after a rather
eventful cross test between the two most
contrary spawn of the Scarlet king and
the findings from that experiment Point
towards a possible long-term solution in
dealing with the interdimensional Elder
evil as well as his children adopted or
otherwise the cross test was the product
of resilient optimism from the research
team who against all odds were willing
to bet that SCP 999 could survive an
encounter with one of the most infamous
ker class scps the foundation had on
record nobody could be 100% sure that
999 would come out of the test unscathed
and there was not an insubstantial
amount of fear as everyone's favorite
glob of goodness was wheeled into a
shared containment for the experiment to
be carried out however the mere presence
of SCP 999 did soothe a great deal of
the worried Souls which only instilled
more confidence in the head researchers
that this would lead to a success once
SCP 999 was alone in the cell with SCP
682 the main event could begin SCP 682
had been subjected to a wide variety of
cross tests during its time in
containment and having never met or been
aware of SCP 999 prior to the test was
cautiously staring the creature down
preparing for the absolute worst with a
beaming smile on its face SCP 999 slid
forward towards the rep
causing the ker class SCP to
instinctively step backward in response
there was something deeply unsettling
about this gooey little glob to SCP 682
but I couldn't fathom what from
appearance the overseers of the Cross
test were stunned the sight of 682
retreating from an entity was rare to
say the least and the adorable
unimposing shape of SCP 999 made the
scene playing out inside the containment
area especially surreal but no matter
how unlikely it seems SCP 999 had begun
The Sibling play dat with an
insurmountable psychological advantage
as the Tickle Monster moved ever closer
SCP 682 found itself backed into a
corner with no further options the
reptile brought one of its massive claws
down on top of the smiling blob the
entire mass of SCP 999 was splattered
into jelly upon impact for a moment it
seemed as though that was it the
researchers held their breath in shock
hoping that SCP 999 would pull through
and then their wish came true the
amorphous form of SCP 999 began to
reshape itself into the recognizable
form that we all know and love it
proceeded to crawl up scp-682's body
towards the nape of its neck once there
the Tickle Monster began doing what it
does best cuddles and lots of them 682
was certainly caught off guard by this
unusual occurrence and more than that it
was falling fast under SCP 999 spell of
benevolence the lizard began to stomp
its claws overcome with sudden bounce of
aborus laughter it began to vocalize in
a way that seemed uncharacteristically
enthusiastic for the ker class anomaly
happy happy I feel so happy repeated 682
as it rolled around and thrashed in the
cross testing containment chamber the
merciless tickling from SCP 999 looked
like it would be torturous for the big
reptile to endure if it wasn't so much
fun on the sidelines the foundation
Personnel cheered on their wonderful
little friend 999 as it continued to
tickle as CP 682 without stopping some
of the staff present were even sporting
custom t-shirts that read SCP 999
literally cured my depression the Tickle
Monster did have a large fan base within
its containment facility after all and
returning some of the Good Vibes that
the anomaly had provided seemed like the
right thing to do at a time like this
SCP 682s fits of laughter continued for
a long while and the more it went on the
more it seemed that SCP 682 was becoming
tired 999 seemed to sense its siblings
energy level decreasing ceased the
Relentless tickling and instead began to
nuzzle 682 and purr into the lizard's
ears slowly the quiet and pleasant
sounds of SCP 999 LED 682 into a
peaceful Slumber the hard to destroy
reptile curled up on the floor of the
containment cell almost like a sleeping
cat and began to gently snore away once
it's older and more tanker sibling had
fallen completely asleep SCP 999
slithered off SCP 682s back and settled
down nearby to rest its own eyes the
research team couldn't help but smile
and observe for several minutes before
eventually removing 999 from the cross
test containment cell predictably this
caused SCP 682 to revert back to its
usual violent behavior and a Containment
Breach ensued shortly after however the
casualties were kept to a minimum as SCP
999 bravely helped escort several dozen
Foundation Personnel to safety by itself
what would we do without 999 we know
what SCP 682 would do without SCP 999 of
course the hard to destroy reptile would
be far less threatened while SCP 999 had
expressed continued interest in another
play date with 682 the exact opposite
sentiment has been reported from its
reptilian sibling and it is simply not a
lack of affection there is an underlying
fear that motivates
scp-682's desire to never interact with
SCP 999 again while some researchers
speculated that SCP 682 felt an
incredible sense of Shame when it was
observed being tickled this is more of
an armchair assumption that projects
typical human psychology onto an
anomalous being we cannot forget that
SCP 682 was born of the Scarlet King and
while SCP 999 possesses the inverse of
its father's traits SCP 682 might have
directly inhered nited the template for
its emotional intelligence from that
very same being While most well adjusted
humans try to avoid supposedly negative
stimuli such as embarrassment anger
sadness and fear and seek out positive
stimuli I.E happiness pleasure security
and Trust alien beings with Twisted
Minds like the Scarlet King might have
these priorities reversed to SCP 682 all
other living things are disgusting and
it wishes to destroy them but when this
tendency is examined within the context
of both SCP 999 and what we know about
the Scarlet King it becomes clear that
SCP 682 isn't an excessively prideful
being moreover SCP 682 doesn't believe
that it is doing the world or itself a
service by eliminating the aformentioned
disgusting beings we have theorized that
SCP 682 and SCP 999 are equal and
opposite but if that proves to be true
on the level of internal psyche SCP 682
might compulsively attack other beings
for the same reason that SCP 999
Comforts them it is a continuous
expression of empathy or more accurately
whatever one might call The Impossible
inverse of empathy SCP 682 and the
Scarlet King are not merely indifferent
to the suffering of others both of them
need to be in the presence of those
suffering beings in order to feel any
sense of meaning in their
existence after all love is the
strongest emotion but hate is the second
strongest imagine now if you can y 682
fears 999 a being that represents every
unwanted sensation and emotion that it
lives its Immortal Life hoping to avoid
in the eyes of SCP 682 SCP 999 is
precisely as horrifying as the reptile
is to ourselves want an anomaly of your
own check out SCP swag.com for
highquality SCP merch the scal class
starship in nois was still suspended
against a backdrop of stars and the
colorful glow of distant nebulas Frozen
in the inky void of deep space calm at
least from the outside but inside the
main hall of the ship was far from the
silent Stillness of the Stars
pandemonium hit as the sounds of a
claxon reverberated through metal
corridors each whale punctuated by the
flash of blood red warning lights blue
looked up at the blinking strobing color
and instantly knew what it meant
emergency meeting he muttered to himself
behind the visor of his space suit blue
turned heel and ran his boots clanging
against the metal floor of the corridor
he ran as fast as he could in his space
suit arriving panting to the cafeteria
his breathless wheezes fogged up his
visor but beyond he could still see the
other six fellow members of the ship's
crew or at least he thought all six of
them were there it was only as he walked
closer that he spotted someone was
missing white red green orange yellow
and now blue were all present but where
was pink you took your time blue white
declared I was over at the lower engine
he panted back it's further away sorry
I'm late ran as fast as I could what's
the situation here orange asked well I I
think we should wait for pink to get
here before we get into red started to
say only to be interrupted that's why I
called the meeting green announced pink
has gone missing but that's impossible
red immediately responded drawing a
glare from White I saw pink only a few
moments ago we we were both over in
electrical to Blue along with some of
the others that seemed a little bit odd
if red and pink had been close to each
other then how had green known to call
the emergency meeting the room erupted
into a brief debate with white implying
in a rather spiteful way that red knew
more than he was letting on interjecting
Blue suggested that they all split up in
search for pink which was quickly shot
down white reminded the rest of the crew
mates that their ship was in need of
constant maintenance if they didn't
perform the necessary tasks to keep it
running then the an nois would never
reach its destination report back here
when you're finished white barked as
they all split off blue couldn't help
but wonder what had gotten white more
agitated than normal however little did
any of the crew aboard the an nois
realized but they had picked up a
stowaway the creature had been slipping
through the ventilation system curiously
watching the assembled group in the
cafeteria before they broke away and
headed off into the various different
areas of the ship spotting one of the
crew mates a man wearing a bright orange
spacit the thing in the vents felt oddly
drawn to him and slithered off down the
vents in the direction orange had been
heading now while you might be forgiven
for at first expecting this extra
passenger to be some kind of alien par
parasite that uses human bodies as hosts
before bursting out of their chest only
to then proceed to kill everything in
sight then you'd be sorely mistaken
stand down sorney there are no
Xenomorphs aboard this ship no this
slippery little stowaway was none other
than the lovable blob of orange slime
known as SCP 999 otherwise referred to
as the Tickle Monster known for being an
adorable amorphous anomaly resembling a
pile of gelatinous orange matter scp-999
has has long been considered one of the
most harmless and affectionate scps ever
cataloged it has a habit of honing in on
the nearest person and leaping right at
them not as a means to attack them or
attach any scary eight-legged egg laying
head hugging creature to any faces
instead as scp-999 offers a loving
Embrace and wholesome nuzzling to a
person's face all the while emitting
soothing gurgling and cooing noises as
well as pleasant scents that change
depending on what the person it's
hugging finds most appealing or calming
while not in any way harmful and only
ever acting out of the most well- meant
intentions SCP 999 had been the one
responsible for Pink's disappearance the
Tickle Monster had been discovered by
Pink while he was traveling through a
corridor past the medbay taking the
longer route back to electrical there
999 had playfully pounced on the
crewmate to offer a hug this had caused
pink to experience the full effect of
SCP 99's anomalous property
slipping into an overwhelmingly elated
state so while not currently injured he
was calmly relaxing in a hidden corner
of the medbay with the rest of the crew
completely unaware of what was going on
SCP 999 had spotted orange and had been
able to recognize the same color as its
own Jello-O like body drawn to the
crewmate the Tickle Monster snuck
towards orange while his back was turned
busy cleaning out the filters in the O2
chamber before he could turn around and
spot the creature as CP 999 leapt to
Orange and lured into the medbay with
pink not long after blue had finished up
his latest task fixing up the wiring and
storage brushing off his hands he began
casually walking back in the direction
of the cafeteria only to see the Crimson
of red spacit zip past he was rushing
down the corridor almost like he had
just been caught well red-handed
something didn't seem right blue thought
to himself red had seemed pretty
indignant earlier when p in had vanished
although he couldn't say with any
certainty if it was because red really
did know what was going on or if they
were just nervous returning to the
cafeteria however the crew quickly
realized that orange was now gone too
I'm calling it now white declared this
was you red you're up to something I
swear I'm not red pleaded it was hard to
see how sincere's expression was through
the tinted space Helm advisor well if
anyone else knows anything or saw
anything then come forward white said to
the group the rest of the crew were
awkwardly shuffling on their feet each
one clearly uncertain but nobody wanting
to come forward and be the first to
speak actually I um blue found
themselves saying I saw red dashing
around in the corridor he seemed like he
was in a hurry or maybe he was up to
something maybe look it doesn't prove
anything you don't know that yellow
chimed in who knows he may have been
eyeing you up as his next victim victim
red exclaimed look I don't know what
you're implying here I haven't killed
anyone nobody said pink and orange were
dead white replied unless you know more
than you're letting on I swear I don't
know what's happening I'm just in the
dark as you all are red insisted in that
case prove it green interjected bluntly
prove you didn't kill orange and pink
how red yelled how can I prove that you
could prove they're both still alive
said yellow completely unaware that pink
and orange were actually still alive he
can't prove it white announced solemnly
because I bet they're not even on the
ship anymore the missing crew mates were
in actuality still aboard the ship in
fact they were having the time of their
lives inside the medbay with SCP 999 but
that hadn't stopped the rest of the crew
turning on red come on red blue sighed I
mean you've got to admit you're acting a
little well not suspicious but
definitely evasive oh sure what just
because I'm wearing red you all think
I'm some kind of murderous traitor red
shouted his desperate pleading tears of
SC by his helmet's visor this is
McCarthyism look why don't you just give
us a straight answer blue offered trying
to remain reasonable and not join the
rapidly growing Witch Hunt because I'm
scared red insisted scared that we'll
find out white yelled leaping at red and
pinning him down quick the rest of you
grab his arms and legs a struggle ensued
with red desperately kicking and
flailing about while green and yellow
gripped an arm and leg blue was
reluctant he wanted to urge everyone to
calm down and not do anything irrational
but it was already too late if he
opposed the blame might shift to him
under White's Direction the crew lifted
red up and carried him to the an no'
outer airlock they threw red past the
inside door which slam shut behind him
as he turned and started slamming his
hand against the surface begging for
them to let him out his pleas fell on
deaf ears as white threw a nearby switch
the outer door of the airlock opened the
vacuum of space pulled red out of the
ship practically firing him out of the
hull like a cannon leaving him to drift
away alone and with limited oxygen in
his space suit right now that imposter's
been dealt with everyone get back to
work white announced we need to keep
this ship in a fit state to move blue
was speechless he thought they were just
going to hold red prisoner in a secure
part of the ship until he calmed down
instead he'd aided his crewm mates in
murdering one of their own even the very
thought of it made blue feels sick and
he would have been if he wasn't wearing
a space helmet it all happened so fast
he'd barely had enough time to consider
all the facts after all white had seemed
adamant from the very start that red was
somehow responsible for orange and pink
disappearing but he had no concrete
evidence to base that assumption on then
again where were those missing crew
mates there had been no sign of them no
bodies or discarded suits maybe they
weren't on the ship at all anymore what
if white was right and red had killed
them or Worse what if White had been the
one responsible and and blue had just
help him kill an innocent Spaceman to
cover up his cruel misdeeds of course
the surviving crew were so wrapped up in
the horrifying moral and ethical
implications of the situation that none
of them had thought to check the medbay
meanwhile SCP 999 had found two more new
friends green and yellow the pair had
seemed rather glum since they had just
helped kill red and so the orange blob
of Good Vibes had sought them out now
the two of them plus orange and pink who
were still fine were all enjoying the
company of the Tickle Monster in the
medbay at the same time though blue was
returning from his task of uploading
data over an admin to find only white
left waiting for him in the cafeteria
neither one of them said anything they'd
both already made up their minds in each
one's head the other was the real guilty
party the culprit responsible for the
disappearances and apparent deaths of
the other crew mates both blue and white
were convinced that the other was truly
the impostor among on
us God in rag they charged at each other
rather than act rationally Maybe by
sticking together and searching the rest
of the ship the two Spacemen engaged
each other in a scuffle you're sus blue
roared punching white in the stomach
causing him to stagger backwards I'm not
the one who sus white wheezed rushing
back towards blue and shoulder barging
him into the cafeteria floor you are
you're sus blue they continued their
scrap trading blows until blue was was
able to throw a punch that cracked the
glass visor of White's helmet there was
a hiss as the air escaped and white was
desperately fumbling with his helmet
trying to plug the crack blue was able
to grab him by his oxygen tank and drag
him towards the airlock blasting his
adversary out into the unforgiving cold
emptiness of space blue staggered
through the ship it was certain that he
received a broken rib during the fight
and hobbled along the corridors towards
medbay when the entrance opened he
stared in disbelief at what he saw sat
inside were the entire crew minus the
pair who'd been ejected from the airlock
of course pink orange green and yellow
were playing with a friendly blob of
orange slime that seemed to have the
energy and enthusiasm of a pet dog the
crew mates were laughing hugging the
Tickle Monster and engaging in tickle
fights clearly in a state of heightened
Elation in a sudden instant of
realization the horror caught up with
blue he had just murdered white and red
for nothing both of them were innocent
in fact nobody on the ship was actually
missing just before this horrifying
Epiphany caused blue to suffer an
emotional breakdown SCP 999 glided
across the floor towards him smiling as
he knelt to Pat the orange blob on the
head blue suddenly felt better about the
two deaths he'd been responsible for
actually he felt great compelled to
start giggling uncontrollably as he
joined his fellow surviving crew mates
in playing with the stowaway as CP 999
although thanks to that delightful
distraction not one of the remaining
astronauts realized that their ship was
still a drift in space heading right
towards a sun things can get pretty
serious over at the SCP Foundation from
world-ending eldrich beings like the
Scarlet King to massive reptiles filled
with hate it can be difficult to find
things to smile about when staring into
the face of unknowable horror day after
day I don't know about all of you but I
could use a break from the neck snapping
sculptures and old men climbing out of
walls so welcome guys gals and and
lovers of laughter come on down and take
a seat it's open mic night here at the
SCP Foundation and we're hoping to give
you a show that won't make you want to
take amnestics welcome to the SCP
explained comedy night some of the
funniest anomalies ever contained by the
foundation are lined up backstage and
ready to show you their stuff so without
further Ado let's get this show on the
road and find out which scps will make
you bust a gut and which ones will be
taking a bad joke tomato to the Head
we've got a bucket of these babies ready
to go in the wings and remember they can
reach speeds over 100 mph so bring your
aame everybody first up coming to the
stage fresh off of a morale boosting
tour around site 19 you know him you
love him he's the sweetest silliest
slimiest guy around it's SCP 999 the
Tickle Monster just because he can't say
anything funny or anything at all aside
from those adorable little chirping
sounds he makes that doesn't mean he
can't get a good giggle out of two of
you sure some folks out there might say
oh tickling doesn't count but those
people just hate fun he may not be a
comedian in the strictest sense of the
word but you just can't keep a straight
face when this guy comes around you've
got to break out in a smile just look at
him go sliming all over the place doing
his thing love that for you oh and there
he goes he found a chocolate bar go
ahead buddy you've earned it do you like
prop comedy juggling do you think it's
the funniest thing in the world to watch
your buddy stuff as many marshmallows as
humanly possible into his mouth and try
not a choke then I've got some great
news for you up next we've got the one
the only SCP
2094 that's right folks it's motor mouth
this guy is an extremely proficient
juggler and circus performer but that's
not all he can fit anything and I do
mean anything into his mouth seriously
he's literally capable of stretching his
mouth up to 2 m in any direction without
feeling any pain talk about
jaw-dropping um and inside he's got an
extra dimension I organ made of some
seriously stretchy tissue I heard some
of you laugh when I said
extradimensional organ that's the spirit
watch as he swallows a luxury sports car
that ugly sweater your grandma got you
for Christmas that overstuffed chair
your ex-wife left behind all that and
he's still got room in his mouth for
jokes too we've all heard about the
various things this next guy isn't
allowed to do with the foundation from
using anomalies to alter the outcomes of
reality TV shows to pranking new staff
members his Antics are as legendary as
the amulet around his neck that holds
his Consciousness and pure Essence it's
Dr Jack brigh this Immortal trickster
has a taste for Mischief even when it
gets in the way of his colleagues
important work we've all been there
sometimes a goof is just too good to go
UNG goofed So What If it threatens to
destroy the very fabric of reality or
unleash a monster with an insatiable
Lust For Blood we'll all learn to laugh
about it later Dr brigh isn't the best
co-worker but he's always the life of
the party and he really knows how to
command the attention of the room just
one thing if he tosses that amulet at
you don't catch it unless you think
complete and total brain death as your
mind and all your memories are taken
over by his sounds like a great way to
end your evening Sometimes the best
comedy is the simplest let's throw it
back to the days of America's Funniest
Home Videos when households all over the
country were ging at the sight of home
movies of people getting knocked into
pools hit in the head with plastic bats
and falling over in a variety of
different ways it might sound terrible
to say but we can all agree people
falling over can be pretty hilarious but
what about a robot falling over what if
that robot was also convinced that it
could destroy you or anything else it
encountered in hand-to-hand combat
pretty ridiculous right don't worry it's
not too good to be true please give a
round of applause for SCP 1370 pester
bbot I am Robo Lord the destructor Ender
of all life tremble before me that's
right buddy you tell them careful
there's a mic cord on the ground there
don't and he's down like a turtle
flipped onto its back can someone um
flip pbot back over thank you thanks
Brian you're my rock give it up for our
sound engineer Brian everybody and for
pbot of course he's kind of a one trick
pony but man that trick never gets old
trying so hard to be intimidating and
then bam down like a ton of bricks I
almost feel bad for the guy almost but
not quite you'll get him next time pal
up next we've got a guy who proves that
when it com comes to Leading an
adventurous life and having the best
party stories of all time size does not
matter get your mind out of the gutter
on talking about SCP 1867 Lord Blackwood
don't judge this book by its cover this
little sea slug defies expectations at
every turn if you believe a word that
comes out of his mouth that is I'll be
honest a lot of what's feeling funny
about Lord Blackwood is unintentional
sorry M Lord but you kind of can't beat
the feeling of hearing a sea slug say
HHO or tell you about the time he
personally went head-to-head with SCP
682 on a Hunting Expedition that's not
to Discount his ability to be funny on
purpose either if you prefer
sophisticated wit over slapstick you can
share some Chuckles with Lord Blackwood
over a glass of his finest whiskey can
slugs have whiskey well apparently this
one
can excuse me I'm in the middle of
something fine okay gez you can have
your turn that very insistent voice
calling to me from offstage is none
other than SCP 2337 Dr speno doctor of
what exactly I'm not sure this Sapient
male corn CR will take your ear off if
you let him sometimes literally not that
you'll be able to understand a word he
says unless you're familiar with the
particularly silly dialect of English He
seems to speak say hello doctor it is me
make sure you keep your distance as this
bird's bark is also as bad as his bite
by which I mean his vocalizations are
Extremely Loud and can cause serious
damage to your ears if you're not
careful but what a way way for your
hearing to go out listening to this
weird little bird talk shout or even
yodel don't think about heckling him
either he might scratch your eyes out
just toss some gummy worms up on the
stage and no one gets hurt speaking of
getting hurt do you like practical jokes
how about television how about mixing
the two together no need to answer
because our next guest is already here
whether you like it or not have you ever
laughed like you come laugh and have all
the fun in laugh starring all your
favorite laughs so ever and always make
go to your
life sorry I don't know what that was
something came over me all of a sudden
anyway here's SCP 2030 everyone's
favorite anomalous TV show laugh is fun
with your host laughy Merson if you've
never seen the show before then well
you're in for a hell of a treat it's a
hidden camera comedy a bit like Punk if
you can remember that one catching
Everyday People in Wild wacky situations
like me meeting a talking dog being
shoved through a mail slot or having
their hair suddenly catch on fire it's a
riot seriously sometimes there's an
actual Riot I watch someone get Torn to
[Laughter]
Pieces there's only one thing this show
and its mysterious faceless host want in
the world to make you laugh because why
laugh is fun don't look up the people
who appear on the show to find out what
happened to them after their appearance
though you might not like what you find
at things on a bit of a dark note there
let's lighten it up with something
beautiful huh how about that does that
sound good to you guys I know it sounds
good to me great because here comes the
most beautiful person you've ever seen
SCP 056 a beautiful person some critics
out there will say that a person can't
have both good looks and personality
that there's no way someone this
supernaturally gorgeous could also be
funny but they be wrong see this
anomalous individual changes to suit the
preference of their environment becoming
whatever would be superior to the person
they're currently with they've
transformed into a large beautiful
Labrador in the presence of a dog a
woman looking like Scarlet Johansson
around a group of young female staff a
gorgeous and Brilliant female doctor in
a white lab coat an impossibly strong
male bodybuilder a woman with cat ears
and a tail in the presence of one
researcher with an anime habit a weeb
and more so if you put them in a comedy
club they'll be the funniest one in the
room by default they can't help it so if
the hottest thing in the world to you is
a sense of humor get ready to crack up
but I hope you've got a thick skin
because SCP 056 has a really nasty
attitude and tends to prefer insult
comedy don't let it get you down though
they're that rude to everybody it's hard
to be the best at everything in the
world without your ego inflating to the
size of the Empire State Building would
you look at that we've got a second
celebrity guest in the room tonight
another performer you might recognize
from inside your TV I hope you don't
think clowns are scary because it's time
for SCP 993 Bobble the clown Bobble the
clown is the star of his titular
television show which features him
learning about all different new skills
of course if you're over the age of 10
you might not have seen the show at all
since folks above that age cut off
become unconscious upon viewing an
episode so if you've missed it I'll get
you up to speed Bobble teaches all kinds
of useful skills for everyday life such
as let me check my notes here cooking
and preparing ing human flesh lighting
fires without drawing attention from the
police silently stalking strangers
through the streets extracting
information Through Torture and um
reaching SCP Containment I I'm sorry
this appears to be some kind of mistake
security could I get security please can
you please get this clown out of
here I'm so sorry about that everyone
great comedy should push the envelope
and bend the rules but there are some
lines that just shouldn't be crossed
like cannibalism and breaking security
protocols if you forgive the
interruption we'll get on with the show
do I have anyone from Boston in the
crowd tonight let me hear some noise for
Boston do I have fish in the crowd
tonight put your fins together yeah
great great well you Boston kns and fish
alike will love our next Kookie
character coming to the mic it's one of
Dr wain's famous little misters SCP 527
Mr Fish love the top hat buddy looking
Dapper looking good now now Mr fish
doesn't do any trick no breathing
underwater or anything flashy like that
he doesn't need to just being himself is
plenty hey what are you looking at you
think this is some kind of joke I'm just
a guy with a fish head okay do you know
any jokes though sure fine uh what do
you call fish with no ice I don't know
what do you call a fish with no eyes uh
fish take care everybody tip your
waitress I'm going home Mr Fish
everybody great guy great guy you'll be
over the moon for this next anomaly on
our lineup he's not crazy he's just a
little bit Spacey I want you to give a
warm Interstellar welcome to SCP 1233
The Lunatic this guy came a long way for
our show from outside the Earth's
atmosphere in fact SCP 1233 is a
humanoid entity resembling a person in
an emu type space suit complete with
visor and propulsion jetpack it's no
ordinary suit either it's resistant to
explosions and x-ray scans as well as
being totally bulletproof but what's
funny about all that you ask some say
laughter is the sound of surprise and
this guy is nothing if not surprising he
arrives on Earth by falling out of the
sky before crashing into the ground like
a meteorite and immediately climbs up
out of the hole and starts looking for
volunteers to join him in the fight
against the moon monsters now the war is
no laughing matter but how can you keep
a straight face when he's mistaking a
cookie for a parakeet or trying to use a
dog to buy more dogs that's Star Quality
right there pun very much intended don't
even think about it though Tomatoes I'm
in charge up here up next we have me I
mean me me me for crying out loud I'm
SCP 426 and I'm coming up to the stage I
am an ordinary toaster that does
everything a toaster is supposed to do
mainly make bread into toast but when a
human being talks about me they're
unable to describe me in the third
person no matter how hard they try
they'll find themselves talking about me
in the first person instead if they're
around me for too long usually around 2
months or more they'll begin to see them
as a toaster and try to plug themselves
into the wall and toast bread not me me
I mean me I'm not a toaster I am stop
laughing this isn't funny get me out of
here not me me toaster
me thank you finally that was horrible
I'm never eating toast again okay that's
a lie I'll probably have a piece
tomorrow can't resist that crunch anyway
up next is the stuff of Legends someone
who's been in the game for years and has
has the most devoted following I've ever
seen put your tentacles together and
give it up for SCP
2662 cthulu he's a Cognito hazardous
entity about 4 M tall with 20 fully
functioning tentacles on his back talk
about multitasking cthulu is a nice guy
no ego to speak of but he's got a bit of
an interesting effect on people let's
call him an acquired taste after someone
has been exposed to him for a prolonged
period of time around 6 months or longer
they'll become increasingly compelled to
do whatever he wants and become a sort
of servant so to get an honest reaction
he'll only practice his standup material
on people he's known for less than six
months I mentioned his fan base before
and I wasn't kidding when I said they're
devoted without meaning or even wanting
to SCP 2662 is able to spontaneously
generate religious followings about once
a month you can't pick your fans no
matter how hard you try and believe me
he's tried everybody wants to be a
celebrity until that Fame comes with
strangers trying to break you out of
foundation containment and perform dark
Arcane rituals with you poor guy he just
wants to be recognized for his sense of
humor rather than his incomprehensible
ancient powers and status as an elder
god you know what we haven't had much of
yet today animal axe that seems like a
real missed opportunity for those of us
who find nothing in the world funnier
than an animal doing something you
wouldn't normally see a monkey making a
phone call incredible who's he calling
the CEO of bananas or how about a cat in
a little business suit hilarious and
adorable well I hope you're not an
arachn because next up we've got SCP
1006 the Communist spiders these little
guys are incredibly impressive
consisting of an organized Collective of
an unknown spider species all of whom
have somehow achieved sapience and
organized themselves into a tiny
functioning government they've used
their webs to spell out propaganda
messages and illustrate portraits of
people's faces as well as developing
simple tools when given alternate
methods of communication that don't come
out of their butts such as ink and
poster paper the SP spiders are happy to
make their thoughts known to humans
don't get too comfortable with them
they're not especially fond of what the
Bourgeois humanoids have done with the
outside world politically active spiders
are pretty great conceptually but don't
let them hear you laughing if you get on
their bad side you might end up like the
skeletal human remains found in part of
their Central web can we um get these
guys out of here actually their little
legs are giving me the creeps speaking
of creeps horror and comedy are often
two sides of the same Coe Co both rely
on the subversion of expectations
building up tension before releasing it
either with screams or about of laughter
just look at horror comedy as a genre or
successful comedians who have pivoted
into the world of scares and shrieks or
for the opposite side look for some of
the horror movies that once terrified
audiences in the days before Technicolor
absurd looking plastic skeletons
flopping around while an actress screams
unconvincingly and runs in slow motion
giant cardboard ants demolishing cities
sometimes something in intended to be
very scary is actually just extremely
funny that brings us to SCP 2006 too
spooky when in its default State SCP
2006 is a spherical entity about 50 cm
in diameter however it's rarely in this
shape for long all that this thing wants
in the world is to scare humans and it
will shift to whatever shape it thinks
will help it accomplish that goal
unfortunately for SCP 2006 and
fortunately for Humanity its sense of
what is scary is not especially well
formed it tends to model itself after
characters from just the type of be
movies I was talking about its current
favorite shape is that of the titular
villain from the 1953 film robot monster
it's a nice effort it really is but when
that big Goofy gorilla suit with a space
helmet on top comes jumping out at you
it's one of the funniest things I've
ever seen do me a favor though if it
tries to scare you just humor it will
you just play along it's the polite
thing to do up next like many of the
people you see hitting up comedy open
mics this next guest has a day job he
won't be quitting anytime soon it's SCP
2598 the traveling moth salesman you may
have some trouble seeing him from the
audience but he's a large yellow
underwing moth wearing a tiny little
helmet he's able to communicate using
Morris code so if you're not familiar
with it you'll need someone to translate
what he says for you no matter what
you're talking about SCP 2598 will
always try to redirect the conversation
towards a specialized helmet for Mom
also known as a moth Helm available for
three easy payments of $1 19.99 I'd tell
you more about it but unless they offer
to sponsor the show I don't think I
should give them any more free
advertising wait a second my guest is
flying away hey hey where you going oh I
see moth's got a moth well they're
giving me the lights so that's my time
everybody now I've got to get to my next
gig I'm hosting Dr Bright's annual
karaoke contest and I just know he's
going to do all of Bohemian rapity again
so I'm going to get get out of here but
first which SCP do you think is the
funniest let us know in the comments
down below and maybe we'll give them
some more time in the spotlight you're a
child awake at night what a feeling in
your room you cling to these rare hours
of the evening and watch the hour hand
crawl closer towards the parts of the
clock you've never seen touched now you
stare out your window embracing the moon
the stars and the Darkness that engulfs
them you trace an owl's hoop who's up
towards the densest Evergreen in the
neighborhood you see a rat Scurry across
the top of a brick wall you wave to your
new nocturnal friends bonded by the
preference of night now you open your
window and inhale smelling the dark sky
like chocolate cake you hold it in as
long as you can very soon you know it
will all be taken from you not by a God
or a black hole or any of the universe's
hypothesized collapse
at this age you know nothing of physical
cosmology you know nothing of the Book
of Revelation you're just a child the
forces that give and take from you are
not understood through physics nor
philosophy nor through numbers nor
thought experiments look at you your
thumb is still pruned from having just
kicked the habit of sucking it your
pajamas are still one unified piece of
clothing cradling your entirety with
fuzzy cotton your teddy bear is still an
extension of your arm not yet removed by
maturity you're still another 15 years
from believing your life is dictated by
astrological signs or personal free will
or mathematical outputs it's not that
you're ignorant in fact you're quite
bright as a child you don't bother to
comprehend the forces outside your house
because you know as long as you are
living inside it they have no governance
the only true comes from within from the
two Gods you have seen with your very
own eyes sitting on the ripped sofa in
Gray sweatpants watching a show about
rich people drinking mimosas on boats in
the Mediterranean the almighty parents
rulers of everything and with just one
compound word called up the stairs they
have the power to take everything away
from you bedtime and suddenly the
curtains are pulled over the world you
long for now it's not the stars but the
ceiling you're staring at but thankfully
You are not alone you pull your teddy
bear out from its hibernation beneath
your armpit and you hug him gently
careful not to squeeze out his stuffing
laying there you can't help but wonder
how your bear got like this so beaten
and bruised torn up like a dog toy one
eye dangling from a string his left leg
bends forward impersonating The Joint
structures of a flamingo yet as far as
you know your best pal has done nothing
but sleep how is he so battered can
hibernation be that taxing do teddy
bears expire the questions for now must
be ignored you lay there together in
your bed fighting the feelings of
Slumber almost as if rebelling against
Mom and Dad's tyranny thinking deeply
only makes you sleepier and tonight you
insist on staying awake it's 9:30 and
you've yet to be sucked into a dream and
that in itself is a small victory but
your parents' wishes will not be evaded
that easily if ever they fight back by
turning on the air conditioning the soft
rhythmic humming of the White Noise
weighs on your eyes and soon you can't
resist it any longer sleep sneaks up on
you the Battle Is Lost a safe 10 minutes
later your parents poke their heads into
your room and see your body stiff and
motionless wrapped in sheets like a
mummy they celebrate their Victory with
a quick kiss and go back to the sofa to
rest like Gods on the seventh day and
While You Were Sleeping dreaming of a
tomorrow where you don't surrender to
the same Powers there is yet another
battle to be fought and if all goes well
you'll sleep right through it but some
children won't be so lucky on July 7th
2001 a Portland Oregon news headline
reported a young boy missing from home
in the middle of the night his parents
were quick to respond that their son
wasn't the type of boy to go wandering
out into the dark and that something
suspicious was sure to be discovered
there in his bedroom the first thing
noticed was his stuffed animal a jovial
Orca torn to shreds its stuffing
scattered across the carpet its head and
body were stationed in the corner
nearest the bed soaked in a black
substance similar to Ink its eyes damp
with water the boy however was not to be
found as the parents held their son's
dismantled Orca in their hands feeling
the weight of mortality they comb their
fingers through the stuffed animals
organs as if giving it an impromptu
autopsy trying to determine what kind of
beasts could have done this but it
wasn't Justice for the Orca they were
after by the time we are old enough to
be parents we've outgrown empathy for
our inanimate counterparts for them the
Orca was simply a representation of the
cruel faith that may have also been
bestowed on their child its death was
only respected for how it related to the
living and so the poor Oro was set aside
forgotten about until investigators
called upon the foundation to intervene
at which point MTF Iota 12 were
dispatched it revealed that the young
boy's room had large Trails of VIs black
liquid streaking the walls the very same
liquid found on the Orca but where did
this liquid come from unfortunately
there was no camera footage to give us
the answer neither were there eyewitness
reports or any residual signs of what
specifically occurred neighbors who were
awake reported hearing the Thump Thump
thumping from the room which as expected
was useless by standard Insight leading
to nothing more than a series of rumors
and speculations maybe it was an
extremely localized earthquake maybe he
was just throwing a temper tantrum but
where does maybe this maybe that lead us
to can factual answers ever come from
this level of uncertainty well one
specific maybe just maybe the key to
cracking this case allow me to explain 2
days after the event the child was
rediscovered unconscious behind a hedge
in the family's Garden a brief interview
revealed that the child witnessed the
final minutes of what he described as an
intense battle he claimed my Orca was
fighting a big monster and then the
monster grabbed me and took me out the
window but someone saw it so it dropped
me and I hid in the bush a second
interview revealed no other discoveries
but the child claimed that the monster
ate his socks initial reactions to the
two interviews were as expected adults
reason the claims were imaginary a
fabrication of the child's mind
manifested to protect himself from
whatever the real trauma endured
actually was but heard beneath the
skeptical murmurs of shed grown-ups
enslaved by their narrow perceptions was
one individual who dared to suggest
maybe just maybe the boy is telling the
truth and it was in the spirit of this
hopeful and trusting maybe that the
foundation would prove the boy's story
to be truth and the truth would be known
as SCP
6330 SCP 6330 is a phenomenon affecting
stuffed animals worldwide though it is
most common in teddy bears manifestation
of this phenomen is referred to as a
sleepwalker event occurring only within
the households of families with young
children typically between the ages of 1
to 14 while you're asleep vulnerable to
what lingers awake your favorite stuffed
animal may find life impulsively
combating enemies referred to as SCP
63302 these creatures typically blend
with shadows though this mechanism is
poorly understood they somewhat resemble
creatures associated with fantasy such
as dragons or ogres always manifesting
beneath your bed no matter how messy or
clean it might be SCP 63302 instances
depict Behavior indicating that they
intend to hurt or prey upon the sleeping
child and it isn't nightlights or
security systems that stop them but
rather SCP 6330 d1s SCP 63301 are
stuffed animals already present in a
child's room that seemed to be
nonanomalous prior to SCP 6330 two
manifestations SCP 63301 has been shown
to instantaneously manifest small wooden
Weaponry in order to combat SCP
63302 to protect their child battles
have been shown to last upwards of 20
minutes and are always near silent there
is an unspoken agreement between both
sides to keep their history concealed as
best as they can in observed cases SCP
63301 have emerged Victorious though are
severely wounded during the Skirmish
torn wool and stuffing are common and
following all known events SCP
63301 have died due to their injuries
but only after sacrificing themselves
for the safety of the child prior to
death the instance will drag the SCP
6330 d2's corpse back under the bed
frame and Dem manifest to understand
this the foundation has conducted just
one test given the volatile nature of
recreating the events the foundation did
not push their with subsequent studies
and so it's the lone research done in
1987 on site 44 that they still lean on
to this day to understand SCP 6330 and
the instances that come with it it began
with a researcher volunteering his
7-year-old daughter henceforth referred
to as subject to be placed in a humanoid
containment room and sooth to sleep
using a teddy bear that she had a strong
emotional attachment to for 12 straight
tests our subject was obs oberved to
sleep through the night peacefully her
environment remaining in alignment with
the trivialities of deep sleep but on
the 13th study something would happen
something very unsettling even for the
foundation standards MTF Iota 12 were
stationed at the room's entrance for
Swift intervention if needed and until
that 13th attempt they felt their focus
to be pointless approaching the third
hour however they felt a subtle and
unexplained value in their presence they
felt something coming on that feeling
while danger is looming that feeling
that makes you clench your fists just in
case and just as they made eye contact
with one another to acknowledge this
shared feeling within the group a quiet
rustling sound Was Heard beneath the bed
and sounds reminiscent of a large
animal's breathing became audible
suddenly a pair of large scaly clawed
hands grasped the rim of the bed frame a
creature resembling a western Dragon
emerged but was it actually a dragon
were the sheets ready to be blasted to
flames if slain would the next regrow
and multiply by the hundreds these
thoughts race through MTF Iota 12's head
one member instinctually ran for the
door to go protect the child but he was
held back and restrained reminded that
the success of the experiment was
dependent on letting the situation play
out naturally it was hard to console
patients at this moment did not feel
like a virtue it felt irresponsible a
creature standing approximately 3 m
above the ground switching between
bipedal and quadrapedal motion was
stalking a sleeping child and they were
instructed to Simply watch for 5 minutes
the SCP 6330 D2 patrolled the room
moving silently and methodically unaware
of the surveillance cameras then SC SCP
63302 turned towards the subject
positioning itself at the foot of the
bed stretching its arms out towards the
subject it gaped its jaws wide exposing
rows of large pointed teeth and a dark
pink tongue it looked like a snake in a
field of mice as it prepared to Lunge at
the subject MTF Iota 12 was ready to
intervene but before they could the
stuffed bear stood up on the subject's
chest and Drew a small sword and shield
from an unknown source almost magically
like switching weapons in an old Zelda
video game it positioned its swords tip
downward and held its Shield at its side
SCP
63301 hunched over slightly and twirled
its sword maintaining I contact with SCP
6330 D2 the entire way through after 10
seconds the SCP 63302 threw its jaws at
the subject and SCP 63301 responds with
a leap towards the subject's attacker
slicing SCP 6330 d2's eye the SCP 63302
responds with a quiet Grunt and touches
its wound which leaks a viscous black
liquid the SCP 63301 jumps towards SCP
6330 -2 and mid battle uses fabric from
the bed sheets to quickly Stitch the
wound attempting to minimize mess and
proof of its presence both instances
went to battle for 9 minutes before the
first signs of damage to SCP
63301 following the severing of one of
SCP 6330 d2's dorsal spikes it strikes
the SCP 63301 with a heavy slap which
sends SCP
63301 across the room it stands back up
placing a hand on its stomach and looks
at its hand which is now covered in wool
and stuffing they charge at each other
once again but as the subject moves
slightly in her sleep both instances
stop and quickly agree on peace until
the subject settles when that happens
the instances resume fighting research
notes that while the battle is genuine
there is an element of guidance they do
not follow a script but it appears they
follow a code while both anomalies
welcome the conflict brought on by the
other neither one wants it broadcasted
to the public after 20 minutes of battle
both instances are heavily scarred and
injured after kicking itself off of the
SCP 6330 d2's nose SCP 63301 Sprints
from one side of the room towards SCP
63302 leaping into the air and Landing a
fatal blow slicing the neck of the other
instance which Falls lifeless to the
floor SCP 63302 is dragged by the SCP
63301 one back under the bed a short
while later the SCP 63301 emerges damage
sustained includes loss of one buttoned
eye exposed stuffing and torn wool it
places its sword and broken shield on a
nearby nightstand s SCP 63301 then drags
itself up the bed sheets towards the
subject who is sleeping peacefully
throughout the test it rests beside the
child lying motionless it seems to glare
directly at the camera and a small digit
protrudes from its round hand giving a
thumbs up to the researchers its head
flops onto the child's cheek before it
ceases to move the father who risked his
daughter for research is pleased with
the discoveries regarding both anomalies
but it brings about a new set of
questions concerning children and their
relationship with the dark these very
thoughts you might even wonder yourself
maybe a kid's desire to stay up past
bedtime isn't so much about wanting to
watch cartoons with curse words or read
Calvin and Hobs maybe it's not about a
desire to be awake at all but rather a
subconscious fear of being asleep maybe
our senses as children are heightened to
the anomalies that creep about maybe all
the fabled fears of children aren't
fairy tales after all and maybe Mom and
Dad checking under our bed is just
performance parenting because even if
something were there would they even be
able to see it or is everything Beyond
an adult's understanding misattributed
to the imagination as we age does our
perception of how reality should look
alter the reality that is actually there
do we indeed see clear with our
expensive glasses from our high-rise
office space or did we see more
accurately in the glow of our action
figure NightLight spying through
stitches in our blankets looking past
crusty eye boogers at what moved in the
shadows it is hard to ever know for
every real encounter a child has with an
SCP 6330 there might be hundreds of
falsehoods the ratio is is truly
impossible to calculate but as long as
teddy bears are Universal so too are
their anomalous enemies and so where
does that fact leave us how do we go
forward should we be afraid to put our
children to sleep afraid of the monsters
under their bed I don't think that's
what our hero would want sometimes we
have to learn to trust things even if we
don't understand them like gravity or
multiplication we have to trust that the
relationship between children and their
stuffed animals are in fact real we have
to learn their loyalty is reciprocated
even if the adult world has taught us
otherwise and if we ever need a reminder
of these lessons we can look to event
184 in Cambridge England where we have
our first recording of a sleepwalker
event outside of controlled testing and
also our first piece of evidence proving
SCP
63301 to understand language and how to
use it to connect with humans in ways
days Beyond being cute and cuddly on
November 11th 2008 a call was filed to
local authorities by a family who
claimed to have discovered footage of a
sleepwalker event within their son's
room mobile task force Iota 12 lucid
dreamers were dispatched to investigate
immediately the footage was seized by
personnel and all members of the family
were administered Class A amnestics the
child's bed swayed lightly as an
instance of SCP
63302 emerges the instance resembl Sy an
unknown creature though it is described
as having a large muscular frame the
instance walks to the opposite end of
the room punching over and observing the
child for exactly 10 minutes as the SCP
63302 begins to stand further upright it
extends a retractable set of claws then
the child's teddy bear suddenly stands
drawing a bow and quiver SCP 63302
assumes a quadrapedal stance and snarls
before lunging Towards the bed the SCP
633 -1 fires a single Arrow towards the
SCP 6330 D2 striking the instance
directly in its Kine like snout SCP
63302 responds with a loud Huff
reminiscent of that of a bull or Bine
the instances battle for approximately
30 minutes the longest recorded
Sleepwalker event to date both show
abilities and skill sets consistent with
other SCP 6330 D1 and-2 instances
eventually SCP 63 33-2 has SCP 63301
pinned to a nearby wall and tries to
strangle it the SCP
63302 then pulls one of SCP 6330 d1's
arrows from its arm plunging it into the
d1's chest then the -2 leans its head
towards the dash1 and Whispers into the
instance's right ear though audio
recordings cannot determine exactly what
was vocalized the SCP 63301 lifts up its
head staring blankly into SCP 6330 d2's
eyes it reaches behind its back pulling
out a small entirely wooden Glock 19
handgun the bear points the weapon into
SCP 6330 d2's forehead and fires the
shot is silent and the SCP 6330 d2's
body falls limp black viscous fluid
sprays onto the wall the SCP 63301 hauls
SCP 6330 d2's corpse Towards the bed
noticeably limping it drags the body by
its large forearm and Dem manif ests
upon reaching the underneath of the bed
SCP
63301 returns and briefly stares around
the room before turning to the child it
climbs up a desk and finds a piece of
paper and a pen it goes on to write the
following note hello Timothy thank you
for always taking care of me it really
was fun I was able to repay the favor of
protecting you unfortunately I am hurt I
need to go I'm too weak to stay and I
just hope you'll remember me it's been
fun helping you I've enjoyed my time
under your care going into this I knew
it would happen the Sleepwalker is
coming for you I'm just happy I could do
my job goodbye my friend I hope I may
see you soon Josie is a half cat no she
isn't half cat half something else and
she's not a humanoid with feline
features either she is literally half of
a cat actually to be more precise she is
the front half but an otherwise ordinary
black and gray tabby cat that is
ordinary apart from having no visible
back legs or hindquarters you might
think that'd make it hard for Josie to
get around but if you asked her on how
only being a half cat affects her on a
daily basis well she wouldn't be able to
answer you due to the simple fact that
cats generally can't speak but
nevertheless Josie will happily and
effortlessly walk around on her own two
legs moving as if she had a second pair
of hind legs in place behind her her
back half isn't invisible it's as if
it's not even there at all not showing
up on X-rays and yet it can give a
slight yield when touched being almost
tangible but not fully despite this
Josie suffers no adverse health problems
or any other complications despite
lacking one half of her body
occasionally she doesn't mind having her
semic corporeal Hine quarter stroked
although she will usually get a little
bit scratchy if people try that so how
does the SCP Foundation keep an anomaly
like Josie contained well it turns out
that they don't really need to she's
perfectly harmless and is actually
allowed to roam freely around the lower
levels of the facility she's kept at
casually as you like she slinks around
the corridors passing from one room to
the next of course if cats could talk
then Josie would probably tell you that
she has the run of the whole facility
the only real question left is what does
a half cat do when she's left to wander
around a foundation facility completely
unsupervised easy she starts looking for
a ball of yarn Josie was sure she'd seen
one somewhere around here one of the
researchers had carried it off for
testing not too long ago her small front
paws patted against the ground as Josie
navigated her way to where she last
remembered seeing that coveted ball of
yarn being taken she passed a group of
researchers one of them kneeling down to
give her a friendly scratch behind the
ears just as she closed her eyes and
purred at the greeting a sound coming
from down the hall startled her it was a
low distress sobbing having never been
taught that old saying about curiosity
and cats Josie slunk past the
researcher's legs towards the source of
the noise the room that the crying was
coming from had no windows no way for
her to get in luckily Josie despite only
having half a body had enough
determination and resourcefulness for
two whole CS
around the corner she knew there was an
open air vent and sure enough she leaped
gracefully up to it with ease the cold
metal tunnel was just big enough to
accommodate her little furry self as she
crawled through the echoing sound of
sobs guiding her as she reached the
great looking out into the windowless
room Josie spotted a tall thin creature
sitting with its back to her its arms
would have been long enough to reach the
ground if it had stood at its full
height but for now they were wrapped
tightly around its legs as as the
creature rocked back and forth its loud
whales showed that it was clearly in a
great deal of distress although Josie
wouldn't be able to understand why
having someone look at its face would
make this slender creature so upset
nearby there was a giant metal cube with
a hole ripped in it and while the rest
of the room was empty there seemed to be
several large red smears on the ground
how strange she cocked her head to one
side and meowed tapping one paw against
the air vent grate it seemed pretty
loose with with a few good pushes the
screws came free and the adorable half
cat hopped down into the room as she got
closer to the creature she noticed it
had a black bag covering its face little
did Josie know an hour earlier a junior
researcher had made the terrible mistake
of putting on a pair of X-ray glasses he
ordered from the back of a comic book as
it turns out these were the only ones to
ever actually work he saw right through
0 96's containment Cube and all hell had
broken loose but Josie didn't mind she
decided to endear herself to the strange
shy creature by rubbing up against its
long leg returning the same affection
that it had so rarely been given it bent
down and gently scooped Josie up in its
spinley arms the pair of them sat in the
corner together Josie getting herself
comfortable on the tall creature's lap
purring as long fingers ran over her
Tabby fur the creature being so careful
not to harm the half cat treated her
like she was as delicate as glass it had
briefly stopped crying thanks to its
visitor and as much as she noticed the
sounds of sobbing had ceased Josie would
never understand the difference she had
made to scp096 his day unfortunately it
wasn't long before their encounter was
cut short a legion of guards in scramble
goggles burst into the room to retake
control of the situation the last thing
they expected to see was 096 sitting
calmly with Josie on its lap and a bag
covering its face but the sudden
entrance of a security team startled the
poor half cat within a second she had
bolted out of the room shooting under
the legs of the guards and back out into
the facility now that she was back
outside Josie recalled her earlier hunt
for a ball of yarn to play with she
still wasn't sure where it had gotten to
maybe someone had moved it pacing over
to the elevator she stared up at the
heavy steel doors the numbers above were
gradually ticking down denoting Which
floor the elevator had currently stopped
at of course Josie couldn't read so
instead she sat and meowed loud at the
elevator maybe if she made enough noise
the doors would eventually open
eventually after a few short minutes of
waiting and growling the doors slid
apart another gaggle of researchers
passed her by and Josie plotted into the
elevator spotting a familiar face one of
the researchers a Doctor by the name of
Sophie cartright was still inside and
smiled down at the half-cat Explorer Dr
cartright had come across Josie a few
times enough for the Intrepid little
tabby to consider them friends where to
Josie Dr cartright asked her hand
hovering over the elevator's buttons as
if in reply Josie looked up and meowed
humans always seemed to smile if she
meowed after they'd said something to
her Sophie chuckled and pushed the door
close button hold the elevator another
much graier voice called a hand or
rather a paw reached out and caught the
doors before they could slide closed it
was another of the foundation's doctors
one with both a considerable reputation
and a very distinguishing look to say
the least Dr C pathos Crow stepped
inside the elevator and pushed one of
the buttons Sophie had to force herself
to keep her head down but couldn't help
herself from stealing the occasional
glance up at Dr Crow she heard the
rumors about A peculiar anomalous event
changing his appearance but had never
seen him up close before Josie on the
other hand couldn't take her eyes off
Crow staring up at him Frozen to the
spot and letting out a low cautious whne
if her tail was visible Sophie would
have seen it swaying from side to side
as The Brave Little half-cat kept her
defensive ground standing between her
friend Dr cartrite and her mortal enemy
you see Dr Crow was a dog or at least a
man who had been turned into something
very much like a dog still capable of
speech but with a distinctively canine
body Crow kept to himself the entire
ride down although Sophie could feel the
tension between the dog body doctor and
her little half-cat friend out of the
corner of his eye Dr Crow spotted Josie
trying his best to ignore her he let out
a low discomforted growl the kind a dog
makes when they're on edge to his credit
he couldn't really help it the man had
been turned into a canine after all but
it took all his stoicism to suppress a
bark and to stop himself from chasing
Josie around the cramped elevator
arriving at her floor Sophie stepped out
followed by little Josie who Moved as
far away from Crow as quickly as she
could the doors closed once more and
sent him further down into the depths of
the facility as she turned turned to
look Sophie noticed Josie had craned her
head up to check on her a were you
protecting me Josie she asked with a
smile bending down to thank the half cat
with a scratch behind the ears before
she could stay for too long Josie and
her human companion parted each heading
down separate winding corridors there
was a funny smell hanging in the air
like something gradually melting and
bubbling only to reform and melt again
filling the half cat's pink nose with a
strange burning scent as she passed a
holding cell something broke Josie's
concentration yet again the noise of a
hand tapping at glass she turned and
instantly meowed a greeting to the
second familiar face of the day albeit a
more beaked face kneeling down on the
other side of the glass the black robed
plague doctor waved politely at the Dual
pod passer by sitting in front of the
glass hoping to be let in Josie gave
another meow I'm quite well the doctor
mused and how are you my dear he asked
politely Josie got up on her back legs
or rather that's what it would have
looked like if she had hind quarters
instead it looked like she was almost
floating in place from halfway down
stretching her front paws up reaching
towards the birdlike face as the mask
Doctor playfully tapped his fingers
against the glass to amuse his feline
friend no I cannot let you in I'm afraid
he sighed sounding a touch more
melancholic not that a half cat can
understand the difference in someone's
Cadence not all of us here are gifted
the freedom you enjoy my furry friend
freedom is not something this
organization would ever understand no
matter how much they claim to know us
the fact of the matter is they never
really listen from the other side of the
glass Josie blinked and cocked her head
to one side confused she'd barely heard
a word he said oh but listen to me go on
the plague doctor chuckled wrapping his
fingers in front of the half cat again I
suppose you'll be looking for that ball
of yarn they took for testing I saw them
carrying the box it was in that way he
pointed and josy's little green cat eyes
followed the direction of his finger
barely able to comprehend what had been
said to her she simply meowed up in
thanks and plotted the way she'd been
directed fwell little Josie SC SCP 049
said quietly from inside its cell
watching the half cat until she had
disappeared from view as she continued
through the lower levels of the facility
Josie slipped through doors seconds
before they closed leapt up onto tables
and dashed between legs that strange
smell was back having caught her
attention and distracted her from her
Quest again tracking it to its source
Josie suddenly felt uneasy she entered a
room with a huge vat of acid the source
of the burning scent she'd picked up on
though it was what was inside the vat
trapped in a loop of regenerating itself
only to be melted over and over again by
the acid that got her feeling defensive
the vast reptilian monstrosity sensed a
small life form outside its tank and
opened one yellow eye squinting through
the Searing burning acid had the tiny
little creature staring up at it the
reptile snarled screwing its now healed
eyes shut and swiping what was left of
its limbs at the glass rearing back
Josie gave the monster her fiercest hiss
bearing her fangs at it the Beast
usually abhor other beings finding all
other forms of life unnatural
unforgivable and so detestable that it
would normally stop at nothing to
eradicate them but today a tiny tabby
cat with her entire back half missing
was standing up to the crocodilian
nightmare and it barely had enough will
to retaliate maybe it was just too
lethargic too tired to try anything
today perhaps it didn't think she was
worth the effort or figured it would see
to her along with the researchers and
guards next time it broke free from
containment and went on yet another
Killing Spree but in Josie's mind this
facility was her home and The Brave
Little half cat had scared as CP 682
into staying put as she trotted away
again she knew that the Monstrous
reptile would have to think twice before
messing with her back on track at last
Josie rounded the corner and arrived in
a familiar looking Corridor she was
certain this was where she'd seen a
researcher carrying the Box containing
the string that she coveted sure enough
she could see into the room where the
Box had been left noticing a group of
researchers and a human in an orange
jumpsuit were gathered around it a few
were making notes on their clipboards at
a safe distance while the one in Orange
stepped closer to the Box Josie watched
as a single bee flew out of the box her
feline eyes followed it ready to pounce
if it came close enough the man wearing
the jumpsuit was waving his arms trying
to swat the insect away a moment later
he grabbed his arm in pain the bee had
gotten agitated stinging him and flying
away somehow surviving as she waited
Josie's patience was rewarded the
researchers and the man wearing orange
bustled their way out of the room
offering her the chance she needed to
zip between them and get one step closer
to her prize the room was entirely empty
save for the box in the center sitting
precariously at top a table wiggling
herself as she readied her invisible and
intangible back legs Josie shot up just
missing the table's Edge she clawed and
scratched at the surface trying to pull
herself up but her lack of hind quarters
made it impossible to climb the rest of
the way dropping back to the floor she
looked up at the table and gave it a
loud indignant meow changing tactics she
started to hop up on one of the table
legs digging her claws into the woodwork
to hoist herself up bit by bit sure
enough her new strategy worked a treat
and Josie was presented with what she
had been searching for one final hurdle
was left however the box was closed now
the struggles of only being a half cat
are one thing but not having opposable
thumbs is a difficulty that has plagued
all cats since the dawn of time but not
being able to grab or hold things with
the ease of a human there's one thing
that cats are great at and that's
pushing things over nudging the box to
the table's edge with a gentle Boop of
her nose Josie eventually tipped the
whole thing off causing it to land on
its side on the floor the lid falling
open triumphantly she jumped back down
to claim her prize expecting to find the
ball of yarn and spend the next few
hours playing with it but something was
wrong the yarn had changed and now it
was looking at her the ball had started
as yarn and ribbon the perfect play
thing for any half cat or full cat for
that matter but the foundation had been
running their usual invasive tests on it
and since cutting a portion of the
string off it had transformed it was now
a ball of meat functioning blinking eyes
staring out of a mass of overlapping
sineu and blood red matter the multiple
eyes looked up at the half cat that had
knocked it to the floor and asked a
single question in a deep voice
emanating from somewhere within its
lipless form are you Eric completely
unfazed by this Josie whacked the ball
with her paw and watched as it rolled
halfway across the room tentacle s Ms of
its body gradually pulled the amorphous
mask back to where it started and then
asked once again are you Eric once again
Josie slapped the ball and watched it
rolled away from her both completely
unaware of who Eric was and a little
perturbed that someone had replaced the
ball of yarn with such an inadequate toy
turning her back on SCP 066 Josie the
half cat searched for a way out of the
room and went back to prowling around
the facility for something to entertain
herself she noticed that she was
starting to get hungry maybe if she got
lucky one of the researchers would sneak
her a piece of cheese now go and check
out SCP 999 the Tickle Monster and SCP
348 a gift from Dad for more anomalies
that are classified as sweet cute or
playful